[Music]
thank you
yeah
round the C4 is going on see all my
levels are sounding see I was doing
everything
[Music]
God never shouts me out
what's going on what's going on
early the Legends we've been here
[Music]
cousins thanks again for getting away
from the M.I.A for my football Sunday
precious ghetto gig I feel you before
Sunday just crazy hurting everybody's
views right back we're in the mix again
Hollywood rules two dollars Super Chat
just thinking the great Pete Peter Moore
no doubt what's going on wins keep when
sweet how I feel I'm feeling better man
I feel like myself you know I still got
a lot of things to take care of on the
back end for long-term Health but as far
as short-term Health people are getting
stronger feeling like myself and I'm
doing better so it's always a good sign
still got more work to do pop novels
going on a fan what's going on that for
me it's a sale I see you what's going on
hindsight with the hustle that's your
new name hindsight with the hustle is
that Hustler motivated
[Music]
I wasn't sure
so see y'all in a bit The Legend will be
in here
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that yoga fire plane they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people don't
aim check my vocals all on Twitter but a
man's social or my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
I am
look You Oughta messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start with
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my TV but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still in my Coastal I
got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and hell is be
swearing ain't real but coming to find
out that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and
snapping and making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start with regardless and people
don't aim check my vocals follow on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social
knowing my CD but I'm still by Coastal I
got you
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns uses the target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
that yoga fire plane foreign
[Music]
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
sounding good give me another mic check
Kings we are now we have now switched
over
okay how's that yeah crispy crispy let's
get the legend real quick uh Lord Peter
Morris look free from my checks I want
to make sure your love is coming through
good on Zoom
make sure you sounded good
yeah what's up guys no doubt my focus a
little off slow solve right check my
check hello ah yes there is the smooth
one there he no doubt all right here you
hear you and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number
323. this is another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's date I'm extremely honored about
our returning guest and we've got the
golden era of Sega Xbox Electronic Arts
and of course Liverpool FC in addition
to the CMA preliminary approval of the
ABK merger Xbox Tokyo game show and
unity's runtime policy to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whose
career is so illustrous to reflect upon
it was only right all Realms reunited
for a proper sequel a true Trailblazer
who fought the good fight for
interactive gaming culture during
tumultuous times as well as an industry
educator who consistently reminds us to
remember the journey from whence we came
introducing the legendary corporate vice
president head of Xbox the legendary
president of Sega of America the
legendary Chief Operating Officer of
Electronic Arts and the CEO who will
never walk alone from Liverpool FC while
owning the Skies of Santa Barbara live
from California and gracious enough to
make his return into the realm of the
Lord my man Lord Peter Moore how we
doing sir
we're doing great thank you and thank
you man you at WWE is cool
I need a hype man and you're number one
on that list great to be back and thank
you for having me back of course of
course we appreciate you Lord at what
you do good to have you back so much to
talk about we had to show you the proper
respect at the round table how have you
been have you been any any time for any
gaming with your insane schedule
uh well there's so much going on here
I've been traveling a bunch and and
continue to do so uh off to Belgium next
weekend that's a a conference uh on
football management and then I can do a
couple of plugs I'm in Amsterdam first
week of November for solana.org and
talking about the future of gaming and
with a look at the past and how we got
here and where gaming is going in the
future and then I'm down in Mexico City
in mid-november at EGS which is a great
conference down there and uh guests of
my great friend uh Mario who I worked
with at EA and uh going down to talk
about my journey to to my good friends
down in Mexico City so uh exciting a few
weeks ahead nice oh I suppose hopefully
doing some gaming in between maybe maybe
on a Volari pillow here and there like
my
best salute salute you already know and
we got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the realm here at the
round table a little extra time
sensitive intros to maximize Lord
Peter's Time by co-host that's the king
dig
my clothes my brother vanilla mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his old
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show back
to back how are we doing sir
doing pretty good right now having
issues with my headset for some reason
it's not wanting to uh I might have to
get the one that uh I still saw sent me
one still in the box so I might have to
go get that one out of the box but what
you switching up to huh which I'd say
yeah definitely go get that one there's
one that I have one okay okay there we
go yeah so first off you'll want to
thank Peter for coming on uh second off
I got I beat that Mortal Kombat campaign
nice single player that that was a that
was a phenomenal experience you know I
have played previous Mortal Kombats
before but it's been decades yeah so I'm
proud of you I know the fighting game
thing is not your genre but to see you
excited I was happy that you did you had
a good time all I had to do was just
find a Spam movement
once I got Liu Kane it was a rap like
he's got so many spam moves I feel you
it was a rap no doubt and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single play
a selfish experience and also the softer
Davis the Lord of clarity and patreon of
the iron bank my man Lord Sovereign PC
Zone how we doing
I'm doing well as you can see I'm back
home from my uh yeah my track my travels
abroad
I Gotta Give a big shout out to my boy
the Mahmoud who helped me down in
Bahrain you know I was I was moving
across the world you know after I had to
unceremoniously have to you know uplift
my life and run around yeah you were
blamed for all the leaks
right fully so it was all my fault
um but yeah you know a big shout out you
know eventually in my travels I I
managed to hook up with some some good
friends you guys may know who they are
yes yes Ed Snowden
um
Tupac Shakur oh my Lord You're
ridiculous and DB Cooper I mean all I
really wanted to know is how is Elvis
doing lately you're really doing well
he's doing well lost a lot of weight you
know okay that's great doing burpees
time on on the Run talk please
but I you know managed to sit down with
the big man and and squash everything so
I get my life back thank you so I
appreciate it I appreciate it appreciate
you sir I just I just you know I have a
I have a gag order the side of the size
of the Bible you know that I have to
adhere to that's it
uh but yeah I'm a little under the
weather so my voice is a little bugged
out and still I still haven't gotten
over this cold it's just not leaving me
but yeah also gaming wise I got to get a
little Mortal Kombat one in nice uh
through on that cyberpunk oh my my mind
oh my
um what else what else a little more
star field so yeah just to you know
playing a little different things here
and there just still testing out the the
goods on the on the brand new pc so uh
nice very nice very nice no doubt and of
course we have the incredible Oak of
this aka the access gamer the prophet of
Xbox Swami King of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
whole the line movement oh beloved Lord
King how are we doing sir oh I'm doing
fantastic we're on to part two thank you
Lord Peter Moore for showing back up uh
it's highly anticipating to paid it for
me and for the rest of the team I want
to give a shout out to NZXT yes yes if
y'all look at the new overlay oh I want
to give a shout out to Sean labrae for
seeing the vision understanding the
vision and making sure the vision came
to completion thank you so much for all
your hard work and your Speedy worst
facts yes fantastic highly professional
guy if anybody needs anything done
please make sure that you check out Sean
labret uh if you don't know his
information hit me up in the background
and I'll make sure that I get that to
you I've been playing Mortal Kombat one
nice now this is the year of the
fighters fighters have made a huge
comeback I don't know in
past history or
um recent history if we had a year this
stacked all we need is virtual fighters
to show up there yeah Peter to talk to
somebody and get virtual Fighters back
yeah
because we have Mortal Kombat Street
Fighter and Tekken launching and then we
have um smaller other Fighters that are
Awards release uh blue blaze and stuff
like that uh King of the fighters these
games are phenomenal and it's bringing
competition back yes high quality AAA
games double A Fighters and you got
addict playing a fighting games
something very very good I hope this
year that the the competition in
fighting game of the year is well
thought out yes because you don't go off
of Just visuals on everything I think
story commands a lot and Mortal Kombat
has my wife watching me play the game
yeah another Realms Ed Boone's on a
different level right now that's
narratively and it was crazy it you know
looking at it initially just from video
before we had it in the house I'm like
it doesn't look that much different
graphically to 11. but when you get it
in the house and you see the level of
detail on just facial expressions
animations mocap stuff like it is on
another level yeah Transitions and
everything I want to give a shout out to
the uh Shaw Brothers run run Shaw and
run me sharp
highly influenced this game thank you so
much it brought back my childhood seeing
uh feudal Japan uh a lot of cues the
martial arts is great so just just check
it out if you're a fighting fan check it
out this game is phenomenal that's what
I've been playing that in fortnite and
Starfield Starfield I'm taking them
bite-sized chunks I'm not trying to
finish the game all fast I do like what
I'm doing I'm cultivating stuff on
planets I'm minding my business having
fun and I think that's how the game was
intended to be uh your journey your
experience told through you and then you
can convey that to others and I and I
really think uh God Howard has hit the
nail okay should be definitely Game of
the Year for me it is but you know
Spider-Man is lurking in the shadows get
to play that no out let's get to it love
it and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that realist in the Roman IOP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to he had shot the Mr
Maddie plays out to finding Duke talking
leaks leaks and more leaks uh shout out
to evanches and uh Thai Guy Travis for
the last word had uh ballistic Kitty on
talking on things Destiny as far as me
pretty much the same as you guys Mortal
Kombat one is finished absolutely
fantastic job by netherrealm Ed Boone
and the team continue to set the
narrative bar in fighting games and it's
not even close it's these things are
interactive movies Starfield the same
thing beat that I'm on my new game plus
is absolutely amazing doing cleanup
achievements there but um yeah that's
been pretty much it for me hopefully it
comes right back this connection comes
back but um yeah solve oh actually
before we start um let's do me a favor
everyone in the community I want
everyone to send a shout out to our
brother will me Hood will me Hood y'all
know him in the community he's been big
it's one of the the biggest hearts in
the community he's going through some a
tough time right now please send them
your love make sure him and the family
are doing okay because will be is a big
part of our community he's been going
through a lot yesterday I just want to
put that out there Saul could you
explain the Rules of Engagement before
we start with uh yeah absolutely guys we
only have Peter for a limited amount of
time so we're gonna wait and hold off on
uh on super chats until after uh
afterwards so we can get the full extent
of the interview in as you saw last time
we were not able to so so yeah so uh
thank you so much for for all of your
super chats and all your messages and
we'll read them afterwards no doubt so
let's get right into it now that we've
been focusing on what the law has been
playing it's been this patient
illustrious guest here been waiting you
know we got to focus on Laura Peta and
more of his illustrious career from his
uh transition from Sega Dreamcast Xbox
360 to becoming CEO at electronic art
cmvp of sports and live entertainment at
unity and of course what led him to be
the uh CEO of his hometown Club at
Liverpool of course it obviously Santa
Barbara Scott so Lupita um I do want to
ask two questions before we get into the
new chapter that we missed with you as
far as you know the old chapter which
was you know we are in the iconic month
of September I wore my special shirt for
you and another year removed from the
greatest launch lineup in gaming with
the Dreamcast or 99.99 as in Tradition
yes of a very reflective uh Twitter post
I saw so what are your thoughts looking
back this month and why does the
Dreamcast still resonate with you so
deeply
well you're right you're right and
before we get in just back to Mortal
Kombat one yes you haven't what the uh
MSG sphere did yesterday in Las Vegas
you're all familiar with the sphere it
had a Mortal Kombat one takeover and wow
stunning so go check it out just Google
it but you'll see the imagery clearly
they did a takeover with the sphere the
sphere is getting up and running and uh
you two are going to be performing there
they're going to be good yes world's
biggest fear amazing but but and key MK1
was right there on the spurious oh
that's amazing that's huge that's huge
so anyway yeah so it's so 99.99 just go
yeah it's uh I always reflect uh and I
reflect
because of the people that were involved
in building what we now enjoy as you
know a completely connected industry and
so from the perspective of what we did
and everything we went through that year
to get to September 9th and everything
we did over the following two years
didn't end up the way we wanted it to
but as I often say we passed the bat on
uh to uh in this particular instance
Microsoft and the Xbox and building out
Xbox Live and many of the experiences
that we have today and we take for
granted bloodly wouldn't have happened
with without the Sega Dreamcast and Sega
net and the games that were powering
that and all of this amazing work this
this trial and error this all you know
fail fast failed cheap that we were
doing in those days to try to get games
to run on on a dial-up modem
smoothly without lag and you know we
were able to do it and and so I always
reflect on that and you know it's it's
it's a little Bittersweet for me because
so many people gave so much
um and
um ended up not seeing the finish line
that they lost their jobs as a result of
this and I think the good news is and I
stayed in touch with many of them that
they all ended up in in a good place
nice and I also uh I also want to give a
shout out for somebody that was there at
the beginning and that was there with me
is no longer with us and and that guy is
Charlie bellfield who was our head of
communications Charlie passed away a few
years later
um
yeah and and a great personal friend
um and and a feisty combatant with the
media uh a fellow Brit uh that um uh
lived and died Sega
any of you that have been around for a
number of years will remember Charlie he
passed away I think it was
2008-2009 but I still remember him and
his contributions to what he was able to
do and and nobody traded punches with
the media
Charlie so so yeah and so every year I
post and I've got a little stash of
memorabilia I'll take a photograph just
so that it's always remembered and its
contributions are always remembered and
the contributions of those people that
work for Sega America Sega of Europe
Sega of Japan the third party Publishers
that believed in us some didn't but but
many did and and I think they would
admit that they learned a lot as they
were getting their games uh up and
running uh to play online uh that they
still have those lessons today as they
do their games here in 2023 that's
awesome I love to hear that kind of
stuff and you know again it reminds me
of the challenge first of all recipes
you know to your friend that's awesome
but it reminds me of again the
Challenger brain that Spirit solve right
of of being competitive and and being in
the mix and you know king that's what
that's what we loved about that era so
much and while we championed it and
again yeah just remember that launch
line I remember King because King had
everything and I remember him and
looking at all like that's we call it
the stack of having all those titles it
was ready to rumble and it just I
remember
your team made it the hardest to pick
usually you know when you're going into
a console lineup oh I'll get this and
I'll get that and then I can wait on the
other stuff you guys made it that you
couldn't miss out on any title and you
know you gave us enough time in advance
to know what the launch lineup was so we
were able to uh save up for that I
remember I broke the bank on um GameStop
I brought in all my DVDs
and I had two duffel bags before we
traded
they stopped the policy after I did yeah
you abused yeah because they shut the
store down in order to catalog all of
them I had enough money to buy the
Dreamcast and every game yes that was
available for up until I don't know it
was bluesting it was everything I
literally had everything so on launch
night I came in and got everything so I
do appreciate you guys for giving us the
best launch lineup in history and no one
has ever challenged that or beat that to
this day absolutely in retrospect giving
it all again and this this is my
personal opinion I wouldn't have done it
that way again there was too much on day
one uh there were too many titles brand
new IP and when you look back and you
think about what we should have done and
again personal opinion here we sit here
24 hours 24 years later and and be
Monday morning quarterbacks
um you know I think ultimately it was it
was over 20 launch titles
and and the perhaps this and the
challenge you have is all of those third
parties wanted to be there on day one
and they had committed and they insisted
and rightly so but what we should have
done is maybe hung a little firmer and
staggered it out all the way to the
holidays and maybe even into q1 of 2000
and so that you were constantly coming
back and looking at Fresh content that
was available but yeah we I mean good
news is I think still that it was by far
the greatest launch lineup anyway
um but but when I think about it you
know it could we have a little bit more
so that it was constantly we had
something to talk about every two or
three weeks the big launch coming along
and so I mean again Einstein is trying
to say 20 20. yeah but that's that's
when I think about it now that's
probably what we should have done fair
enough and I've totally understand the
insight there another question I want to
ask you from one of your previous errors
before we get into EA and all the good
stuff
um you know before that I wanted to ask
you an Xbox specific question because I
think you are uniquely qualified to
answer this and this is based on the 360
era of having the huge IP like the Gears
of War the Mass Effect I need your
thoughts on the idea of Xbox kind of
making exclusive gaming deals or Studio
Acquisitions versus PlayStation with
what some may consider like organic
growth of generally working with a
studio or helping with their games
before they acquire them like what are
your thoughts on this subject as far as
that process on both sides
you've got to remember that Sony had
been uh building relationships with with
third-party Publishers and delivering
large profits to those Publishers since
the mid 90s and so they had had the
benefit of particularly with the
Japanese Publishers you know this hand
in glove relationship of the first party
and third party and so what we had to do
coming in close to a decade later as we
really got up and running with the Xbox
360 is we had to kind of insert
ourselves in between that relationship
and as I said on on on our first meeting
here is that there was a lot of
skepticism as to a would we deliver a
competitive consult or the competitive
price that would be supported with great
first party content
um yes we did and secondly were we in it
for the long run again there was still
and and it's difficult to to imagine
that as we sit here today but there was
still a lot of question marks of whether
this was something that Microsoft was
eventually going to you know bury the
Xbox
it's a great effort you know and tech
companies like this uh with that size of
a balance sheet can afford to spend a
few billion dollars to see what happens
and and if it doesn't happen you know so
be it you you you read a story last week
about Microsoft and how much they spent
on their own AI yes before they went in
and so you know and billions of dollars
and they went you know what let's go to
open AI
and so um so yeah we had to build those
relationships and I spent a lot of time
in particular going to Japan working
with obviously the Publishers here as
that continued westernization of our
industry was going on writing large
checks as I said last time but building
out you don't just willy-nilly write the
check you think through what is it worth
to have this content on our platform how
does that drive hardware what are the
royalties we're going to get on the
software and what does that do to the
other guys
um you needed you needed to you know
take away the competitive advantage or
at least be on an even footing so that
you could they'll say we got this we'll
say we've got this and and you go at it
software drives Hardware uh you know
you've got to be able to at least point
to the fact that whatever genre whether
it was a shooter whether it was Sports
whether it was action adventure whether
it's RPGs the you had things
um and as we mentioned last time you
know our launch lineup in particular the
Gears of War yes um and then thinking
through some of the stuff we needed to
do to kind of soften the brand so we
weren't seen as a shooter box
um yeah and you go you have to maybe
acquire Studios to be able to do that
and we were not afraid of doing that and
again we had the balance sheet and the
uh the cash that allowed us to do so no
I respect the answer because I guess the
only reason why I I agree with you
because I think that I have a little
push about because I feel like P people
feel like there's this right way to do
things and there's this pure way to do
things and again when you're the
Challenger brand and then you made a
good point about these relationships
with you know obviously a Japanese
company and these Studios and things of
that nature it's an uphill battle to try
to you know penetrate that and then
obviously obviously what you just said
about Microsoft you know showing their
commitment to the gaming space right
that that was something that you guys
had to prove yourself so I just thought
it was interesting that you you kind of
agree with that mindset of hey we have
to go out we have to acquire what we
have to do these things to to stay
competitive
yeah I mean we needed we needed a race
we got Project Gotham Racing from my
great friends at bizarre Creations in
Liverpool to balance out maybe Need for
Speed you needed something in those days
to compete with Gran Turismo when we
built organically turn 10 Studios which
we built internally and and you know we
just put the word out who wants to be
part of a racing studio and you know it
was enough Talent there in Redmond
Washington that we could build it out
and and man and that that IP continues
to this day as we know and I was I was
very proud of what we were able to do
with Forza in particular to
counterbalance Gran Turismo which was a
behemoth and and maybe still is but
certainly was then and so you know you
either go acquire a studio or go get a
publisher a developer or you just build
it internally and you make that decision
build or buy
um and you know that's what we did and
and we had to we had to be able to stand
on stage at E3 and feel good about what
we had to offer against the other guys
really good to know I never knew and and
some things like Escape over a period of
time I didn't know that you were there
during that time of building turn 10 and
we it started King before me but we
certainly you know I can you know they
they were a sconce there now Millennium
Studios and it was very much organically
built it was people it was a combo it
was a combo of people that are a thirst
for for car culture and stood and then
because it's a deep game like a Gran
Turismo you build your car you spend a
lot of time doing that we had a lot of
Engineers at Microsoft and so they we
had this and then the sense of
authenticity that we needed to like get
going and so great little story you know
I'm a Aston Martin guy and I've had
Aston Martin since I actually my first
one an old one that I I got it um in
Redmond Washington and when I was there
and I got a call one day from the
geyserton content said we need a V12 uh
Aston Martin for the authenticity to
maintain the license you have to to have
your license you don't just put any V12
exhaust in there you need to have the
authentic engine noise so I said sure I
got I got mine it's an old one
so I gave it to them and and what
happens is when you're when you're
recording audio you put microphones in
the manifold and so you're grabbing that
authentic car audio of that model of
that engine and that's what you have to
do to maintain your license so
um and you know what they called me the
next day said good news is we got the
audio bad news is we blew out your head
gasket on your car oh
laughs
yeah the entire because you Redline it
which means you push it all the way
through maximum revs and yeah it was an
older car and the gasket couldn't quite
take that and blew it out anyway all's
well that ends well I think I said Phil
Spencer and Shane came to build a
meeting I could just I could just see it
now it's like okay I guess I guess just
tell it to the shop from there
no no thanks man that's a wonderful
story yeah
you've got to like punch counterpunch
what have you got this is what we need
here and then in those days where it's
very much you look at your genre and
you've got to check those boxes and and
you know we can talk about sports and a
little bit right now yeah we want to
already needed that as well so yeah I
appreciate it I didn't know that that
was uh fantastic yeah that was fantastic
Insight so let's talk about your tenure
what we've missed and that transition
you know saying for president of EA
Sports Chief Operating Officer at
Electronic Arts starting that new role
what that entailed at the time and oh
Peter why did you sneak out the back
door of Xbox when while you were on top
what was that about
well a little bit and and the viewers
and listeners will will go through this
in their careers you you make decisions
for for different reasons and just more
money or you feel like it's a better job
your your family uh you know your
situation with your kids and where
they're going to school and then you
know we were kind of Bay Area and so the
ability to come back to the Bay Area
um you know to Electronic Arts based in
in Redwood Shores on the peninsula South
of San Francisco and it was a
combination of my sports background at
Patrick and Reebok uh and then my video
game Background by the time obviously
Sega and Xbox and you know I I got a um
I got an email from a recruiter and this
would be in the uh spring of 2007 and I
always remember the subject line says
time to come home
and you know you open those things right
and so it was very much John riccatella
was coming back to ea uh they were
building out reconstructing the
organizational structure of the company
into what's known as labels and so it
was the games label Sims at that time
was a label on its own because it was
and still is a massive massive part of
the EA business and then Sports and so
the attraction for me a I would be
president of EA Sports and B I would
have not only control of of marketing
but also development and having the
two-core studios in in Vancouver and out
in Orlando and that for me was was
incredibly tempting and again a stretch
for me because I'd never had development
under my wings but I I was looking
forward to learning about it and getting
involved with the studios and the heads
of development and I knew that that EA
was poised to to go forward here into
what was this break new world that was
percolating of the digitization of our
industry
and so yeah and it was it was hard to
leave Microsoft and and great friends in
particular Robbie bark and yes remember
the day that I sat down with Robbie and
just said look I I have this opportunity
um I was never going you know there was
no further upward Mobility
Microsoft and and I loved it there
wasn't a fan of the weather
as a shot of Washington what are we
doing
kind of dreary there yeah yeah like
Manchester but on the West Coast
yeah so it was just there and it's it's
uh yeah
and so getting back to the Bay Area was
was important and I just had this sense
as I did with Sega that that EA was on
the cusp of something and that they
recognized what was going to be the
future of the next few years and there
were very few uh Publishers that had
that structure and that foresight to to
go forward here and I felt um and I
wanted to be part of a of a third party
at Ben first party obviously and then a
little bit of third party was Sega but I
like the idea of worrying less about
hardware and worrying more about
software and content
a great points I totally get it and this
amazing opportunity happens for you you
get the call you know it once again
there he is King right on to the next
challenge as he knows you know something
last night I pulled up your Wikipedia
then I started doing digging right you
know past the Wikipedia into the digging
and I said and I had a Eureka moment
I said this man has either he's a
futurist either he's a time traveler or
something because you have been on the
Forefront of where the industry is
always going right you were on the
Forefront with uh Broadband right
um You was the on the Forefront with
online gaming and then you on the
Forefront with the digital um because
you just brought it up yeah and moving
from spot to spot space to space and
getting to EA and EA people really don't
realize EA started the free-to-play the
mitral transactions and the going
forward and you was essential at the
helm at this moment
um I know Cog has yeah if you don't mind
yeah I'll let him set up you know you
set it up perfect what I was gonna ask
him because you know again Peter being
right there in the mix and I want to
talk about if I remember was EA access
before it was you know what is this now
EA play right or whatever what is now
but you know this was during your tenure
right the the subscription service you
know in gaming so to speak and and let's
be honest with Pete a lot of people had
a trepidation you know initially about
you know physical game ownership is this
the correct way to go and you know what
are your thoughts about that and you
know this Subscription Service future
which you were a part of that addict you
you can actually argue that EA access
probably opened up like either the
concept because I'm sure maybe other
people learn uh you know heard that you
guys are doing something like that that
led the door to something like game pass
down the line because if I remember
correctly e-access was before Game Pass
I'm trying to remember help us remember
the timeline uh Lord Peter because I
felt they were really close there
yeah so let's go back to the real
beginning at EA okay
and so this will all perfect for us from
all of this so I I I I you know I I get
a nice note from from Bill Gates I get a
nice note from Steve Bauman which which
is which was great and then and then I'm
off and and yeah I had to get through E3
uh still as a Microsoft employee knowing
that I'm moving to EA and yeah you might
recall that was the E3 that it was in
Santa Monica where we were experimenting
you know away from the big LA Convention
Center
and and it was a it was a failure as an
experiment this was also this was also
the E3 where we were debuting rock band
uh oh that'd be three yeah
yeah we were excited about this and of
course me being the fool that I answered
you know why don't I go on stage with a
guitar in my hand with the guys with
Alex
from from harmonics and uh and do rock
band and so we're in rehearsals we're at
the at the um at the Santa Monica ball
there and and you know it's a huge show
and we're live streaming and Jeff Keeley
was getting up and running with this
thing and I think G4 TV had it live and
everything is fine uh you know I'm
getting the buttons right and we go live
and I suddenly realize as we're playing
live there's a little bit of lag between
what I'm seeing on
20 20 feet in front of me in the
audience and me hitting the buttons to
get the Rhythm right and of course and
if you remember what it was like you
needed to stay in and and your bandmates
could keep you in if they could give up
but that I hit the pause button
and pause the entire game oh
and and you'll find it on YouTube as
clearly half million other people have
and just one of those where it you know
it was funny uh people remember it you
know classes
again it's these things you're doing to
try to promote and I thought I can do
this and uh clearly I couldn't I mean
I'll figure it out because we have not
figured out that the latency and the lag
uh from and and so and then the next
night great story we decided to redeem
ourselves in the Troubadour in West
Hollywood and we opened up for a Stone
Temple Pilots
we got on stage and it was perfect
I'm not gonna take this loss yeah he had
to get back out there yeah I'm gonna get
my look back I can proudly say which I
often do that I've opened up for Stone
Temple Pilots
so so let's let's that's the first
meeting I'm still a Microsoft employee
coming out of 33 and I get permission to
attend a critical EA meeting uh hosted
and shared and presented by John
riccatello
um and it was called The Burning
platform meeting it was in the W Hotel I
think in 56th in Lexington and in New
York City and it was kind of VP and
above and and John was going to present
what he felt the future was and a
burning platform for those of you that
are not familiar with it is kind of a
business term that everything's fine now
but there's some little Embers starting
to flare up and you know
platform but eventually it's going to
burn into the North Sea so the first
slide was a oil rig in the North Sea
okay second slide that oil rig is on
fire I mean raging and I'm thinking wow
what have I what if I helicopter into
yeah and and Jr was making the point
that look things are great a lot all of
our retailers are buying lots of discs
uh and we're doing great with our Retail
Partners around the world but the future
is going to be digital uh Broadband
speeds are going to increase hard drive
sizes memory will increase and the
future is direct to Consumer download
and from that from that meeting that day
and John was also very clear he said
many of you won't be here next year
oh yeah
and and you know you're doing great but
it may be that you need and I'll give
you this opportunity to go find
something else to do either elsewhere in
the industry
um because your skill sets will either
evolve and will move digital and you'll
move with it or you go find something
else to do and many people did and they
have actually appreciated the heads up
of the The Times They are a changing to
quote Bob Dylan and it was very much a
meaning and what is that 16 years ago
that that I will never forget and it was
a foresight into the future of what
gaming was about to be but this idea of
what's known as creative destruction
which is when things are going well that
is the time to start blowing up your own
platform
destroying what you've got to think
about what you need to build to be
relevant in the future and and that's
what we started to do and this these
were difficult years for EA because as
king said we decided we're going to be
at the Forefront
of downloadable content you know um
DLC and microtransactions and ultimately
free to play as we moved into this
digital era and what we needed to do as
a company as a global entity is move
away from manufacturing disks and
working in warehouses full of boxes and
carton shipping to GameStop and Best Buy
and Target and HMV and Virgin records
and all of these Global retailers and
start thinking about building back-end
infrastructure Global billing systems uh
customer service which I was responsible
for by the time you know we got into the
head of this because I was then Chief
Operating Officer and building out
Austin Texas and Galway and Ireland
because when when your your customer is
a retailer your your account managers do
customer service right and we went from
literally 18 or 19 EA employees that
handle customer service to 800. as we
moved into you guys you guys being our
customer
so it was a it took hundreds of millions
of dollars in back-end investment new
Talent new strategy new focus and and EA
stock went down because anything money
we made we reinvested immediately into
building out for the future and that's
what that's what creative destruction is
all about you know you can't be you
can't be a Luddite you know you
smash the machines you've got to embrace
what's coming make difficult decisions
see the future and invest in it and that
was that period of time you became
Public Enemy Number One oh yeah because
exactly for for the for the retailers
like for for uh Best Buy and all these
other people because
the consumer actually knows what they
want but
I know for a fact that the retailers
understood that you were directly
removing said profits from their pockets
because you're going direct to Consumer
so there's no middleman in between this
that you have to break off any money to
it's really you guys and the consumer
and how did that feel because I
understand I know that became Public
Enemy Number One
how was the temperature in the company
at that point when y'all decided to do
the digital and make the 800 employees
and all that stuff the temperature had
to be I don't know talk to me and then
I'm just going to add to that because
it's along the same lines what was their
pushback in terms of the switch to this
sort of multiplayer type of thing and
and moving away from single player games
that each EA has sort of been known for
I I said it I think it was in 2010 that
all games would be online and and that
caught all kinds of abuse because people
and you know I I don't want to play
online I want to play single player and
what I was saying is every game would
have an online element to whether it was
full multiplayer right or you could
where's your stats where's the
leaderboards where's the tournament so
and every step in between and so you
know that caught all kinds of abuse but
to King's question yeah it was some
difficult conversations with retailers
who are saying wait a second you know
you're taking my customer away yeah and
you know the the big guys The Game Stops
were surviving uh and actually
flourishing jurors
because of disk trade-ins right it was
you know very much like you buy your
copy of Madden you play it for 59.99 on
day one you play it for two three months
you go yeah I'm gonna trade it in
because I want to buy NBA live in those
days or some or NHL or something like
that I'm gonna go back to GameStop
they're gonna me fifteen dollars credit
they're gonna smack it on the shelves
right
boost that price back up
fine but but all of a sudden the storm
clouds if your Game Stops start
Gathering because we're we're delivering
it digitally not physically and there's
no trading on digital that's right so
this was and and so the the retailers
became the luddites they're trying to
smash the machine and uh and and and
look I mean many of them survived and
flourished and still found a way uh to
to to figure out their business changing
in in light of this and you know Muse
they've gone through the same thing in
music you think about it in the old days
and they had 80 linear feet of CDs I I
don't even know if they sell CDs anymore
I'm sure they do but people still want
that but this was a fascinating period
and yes I mean there was a Coho a large
cohort of Gamers that that just didn't
like the idea of this we still kept
shipping discs and we kept still working
with our Retail Partners but we were not
in any way uh inauthentic about our
intentions and we said look we're
building out back-end infrastructure and
and we're going to be delivering this
stuff digitally at the same time to the
question feels like a long time ago now
about subscription yes yes we started to
think about the future of what
subscription Services would be is there
because of course you know this is the
height of Netflix just taking off and
all of the
because of the power of broadband now
you could start selling subscriptions
because it was a consistent experience
you could have whether it was content
whether it was video whether it was
music this was the beginning of you know
the early days of a Spotify account
soon
yes yeah yeah that was me
I don't know if you remember Origins
PC and we started to experiment with
with subscription services that have
buckets of benefit a direct to you
consumer B discount on the game up front
see Early Access of the game on a
Thursday night when the game was
shipping at midnight
morning
and having that ability then to go into
a vault if you remember yes the Vault
play all the games so you had discounts
Early Access and Vault and origin which
we we started playing around what
happens in this world of business when
you're being disruptive and you're doing
things that nobody's done before is you
try things and again is this Mantra of
fail fast fail cheap is that working
what is the game saying are we seeing
pick up on this are we seeing more sales
with albeit discounted but are we seeing
that what is the engagement in the Vault
of games that we would put in the vault
that be good you know EA access and and
you know we knew
there would be a time and maybe that
time is is is coming that where you the
streaming of everything would be you've
got a thousand games at your disposal
here and you just go out you don't need
a disc or you don't even know that need
the full game download but you play that
game
um you know and jump right in uh from uh
from a platform and this would this was
the predecessor to what we're all seeing
now this movement towards uh streaming
services yeah I'm sorry okay did you
ever think about
um the day and date
uh into the service
because I think they had what for what I
remember correct me from Peter it was
like you could play Madden or whatever
day like eight hours or something like
that only ten hours yeah tell us
something like hours you trial it I
think it I think it was more like three
days and so okay you know what happened
different than the old days of what's
known as a gold Master disc
because you kind of went gold uh you
know 10 days prior if you will you went
final maybe it was two weeks prior I'm
sure and that gave you if you've
downloaded the game we would allow you
then to get Early Access yes yes and so
and I think it was typically over a
weekend and so I think in my mind a that
was a huge benefit that the bragging
rights I'm I'm playing Madden this
weekend and B it allowed us a little bit
to start seeing what the engagement was
what was working what wasn't working and
if you had a good game which most of the
time thankfully we did Word of Mouth
from the gamer rather than from May
would go through this is the time now
social media is really kicking off and
so I'm talking about a decade ago and so
you would see that buzz online hopefully
that man this feels good this feels
better than last year this feels like
what I've always wanted from a Madden um
you know in particular here and so
um that was the idea of doing that and
monitoring over the weekend load
balancing on the servers do we have any
problems is there any are there any
glitches that we haven't spotted here
that was going in there so you could be
ready for your full launch of 1201 a.m
on a Tuesday when people had pre-loaded
the game if you remember yes you go live
right and so you we flip the switch and
the game is live yeah no that that was
huge and um again I love that we're
mentioning this because you see you know
King this was a predecessor to a lot of
what we see now with Early Access and
and given the game and then the word of
mouth spreading and let's be honest the
fomo from the other game was like man
he's playing the news right now I could
jump in and we're seeing you know the
results of that that model kind of being
copied but I do want to you know give
you you know your flower was in
reference to again when you talk about
blowing things up at the time of success
you know when physical is rocking games
are being you're making money hand over
fish but down the road you're looking at
that all right you're looking at that
that burning thing and if you don't
adapt right you could be left behind and
I think it it's it's pretty ambitious
but it's also scary right because you're
betting on the future that that's not
there yet so I I respect obviously John
saying that to you know to to the
company hey you know a lot of you guys
won't be there for you you know this is
not something you're on board on you
know kind of move on but I guess my
question to you Peter and reference to
this because I see this coming up a lot
which is betting on that future and all
that investment but then sustainability
and I guess my my question is like you
know a lot of people have the
trepidation where it's like you know is
this sustainable with these
subscriptions or like what's your
thought process or on investing on
something in the future that's not there
yet but you you
store your metrics you see where it's
going
well
We believe We we knew and but we also
were were we knew what it was going to
take to get there so this concept go
back of creative destruction was
developed by uh austrian-american
Economist called and he he had said this
is how Industries get destroyed the
steel industry in America you know just
you don't evolve and then everybody else
eats your lunch elsewhere and you've got
to be willing to blow things up even
though they're doing just fine so you
can be ready for this next iteration of
business and and all of the environment
the ecosystem that is the new business
and so this is what we saw
um and John and the executive team
include myself we built for a digital
future and boy did we take the brick
bats and the abuse and whatever
we were we locked arms on this and we
knew and and Wall Street hated it
because we just weren't delivering the
margins because everything we were
investing in was based on something that
was going to deliver two three years
from now yeah and our stock went down to
less than eleven dollars wow and that
was tough for for you know many of us
that in the industry or you know your
compensation is is built on Equity a lot
yeah so it's like this is this is my
future and you look at your your your
vested grants of something that may have
been a 50 bucks and now it's worth 11.
So you you're nervous but we stood our
ground and we stayed the course and yeah
I was gonna say I think one of the
biggest things that like really because
I remember when EA access was first
announced like it was that 30 year
option and I remember so many people
just gravitated towards that it was it
was it was it was insane like it really
was and then and then Game Pass was
announced but at first game pass didn't
have games game day correct it it that's
something they added later on no
absolutely so you're a competitive
spirit
at this point because all right now
you're down right because you know your
stocks go to under 11 you know and you
came from a thriving situation and they
show you an oil rig burning and you like
all right yeah okay so we're on the oil
rig right now we got to put out these
fires but we understand that this is
going to the Future
your thought process as a fighter you
knew everything lasts in seasons and
this season Shall Pass itself yeah going
forward yep going forward
what was the main thing that you can say
that y'all held firm on that bear fruits
later
that gave you all the most trouble early
on what was the main thing that you held
firm on
well I think
and again what Gamers take for granted
which is massive back end infrastructure
of service systems customer service
um seamless uh digital experiences that
takes hundreds of millions of dollars
and particularly when you're a global
company all of the stuff that we had to
do to evolve from being a company that
presses disks and ships them to a
retailer and then goes like that to a
company then that actually is delivering
digitally and then at the same time
building live operations because now
you're digital and now you've got access
to a gamer's hard drive you can be
updating all the time to to to to a to
give better gaming experiences and B
quite frankly to give the company more
opportunities to commercially engage
with the customer rather than once or
twice or three times a year as we were
doing and hope they'd come back again A
year later for what was known as the
last three feet of the sale which which
is the reach on the shelf and then just
going back we now saw a future where we
could engage every day 24 7 and and the
game formerly known as FIFA became the
gold standard and and that's where we
started investing in what we believe
would be because you've got a game that
reflects the real world of soccer which
changes every hour of every day with
with scores in South America Scores in
Asia injuries player transfers red cards
penalties VAR all of the things that we
do and and the story lines uh that that
are there and then we developed the
thing called The Journey yes
so so what so in answering your question
came we just believed in this future of
software as a service which is a kind of
a productivity term productivity
software term but we we saw that as the
future here rather than make game put it
on the disk send the dev team to the
beach for two weeks come back rinse
repeat this was going to be live
operations and a service but but a lot
of pain oh a lot of money
needed to go in and a lot of abuse oh
yeah fine uh as we moved away because
I've said it 100 times Gamers don't
necessarily like change you know like
James we scared we scared of that future
and look you know and and so we bluntly
saw the world very simply think of an
inverted funnel and all of a sudden it's
it's three things it's acquire engage
monetize that's the way the world Works
digitally and you open that funnel wide
where everybody has access and this is
where free to play games came in you
engage deeply by great content great
engagement fresh updates all the time
and then ultimately you monetize instead
of monetizing at the top of the funnel
yeah you've now got if you maybe you've
got a million people playing your game
now you now you've got 10 million people
playing games because why would you
because it's free right you lose a lot
that that don't quite engage where
you're at and you certainly lose a lot
that don't want to spend money on the
game each day or each week or each month
but that is the way that we saw the
world emerging and that's the way the
video game industry whether it's
consoles
that's where
yeah I gotta beat your chest on that one
you're preaching and I love the
education here because again as Gamers
look we are afraid of change and I get
it we we resist it we're stuck in our
ways we're so used to the thing but
that's where it was going and that's the
reality of the business I want to Pivot
first a little bit in reference to what
I consider like the pizzazz of what you
did at EA like you you were in the
entertainment business and I thought
what was really interesting is like the
the the the marriage of the sports and
the athlete and I remember seeing you on
these stages and you know Muhammad Ali
is there and the who's who of sports and
like what were your personal standouts
moments at EA in conjunction with all
the other things that you did in
reference to athletes and sports and so
forth
well yeah I mean yeah we heard Muhammad
Ali which which is an amazing experience
for me and and the ability for us to be
able to for me and a great story
um is we had him at E3 and I'm trying to
think what year probably
2008 maybe and of course his Parkinson's
tragically with we take it what Muhammad
was doing then was communicating through
little magic tricks he could no longer
speak
um you could whisper a little bit but he
was uncomfortable and embarrassed you
could tell that this is for me one of
the greatest athletes ever lived not
only you know in the ring but what he
did oh yeah culturally yeah so so and a
great story that I will never forget is
that my job was to actually sit with him
off stage and there we had a a big
screen uh that shows you what's on the
big screen at our E3 stage and I think
at that time it was Robbie bark was on
stage with with Don Matrix
these days and so
um and I'm sat with Muhammad right there
and a moment I'll never forget and he's
he's pulling out his handkerchief and
he's got a little ping pong ball he's
playing with and he's watching the
scream with me and Halo uh Halo 2 I'm
sure it was was on the screen okay and
master chief Jake takes out a brute who
goes down hard like this and he leans
over to me and goes down goes Frasier
yo classic classic
body goat okay
whisper but it was
and I still when I say it the Goosebumps
or you know that oh
I know Frasier going down
goes Frasier oh that's a moment never
forget that moment
we got Muhammad on stage and he was very
frail and and but it was just wonderful
to be breathing the same oxygen
absolutely absolutely I mean Legend and
what's beautiful about it is you can see
still sharp as attack you know inside
and they have a moment like that with
the kick that's got to be crazy I mean
anytime you get a chance to meet him
I've met him one time I used to box
he looked like he had a glow on him like
it was just something I can't really
explain but to me it looked like he had
a glow and I guess that was the moment
in my life I just thought I would never
get that opportunity but that's a
beautiful he like when you meet him
there's an impression that will stay
with you forever absolutely absolutely
now Lord Peter I gotta be fair I gotta
have some tough EA questions now
so so you know look I want to be real
with you because you know as a person
I'm such a sports guy right like you you
know I'm a sports guy I follow my teams
you know EA Sports It's in the game
remember you know the little logos we've
been following it for so long and it's
synonymous with my gaming and I guess
with me you know I listen I get the
dominance of FIFA like FIFA is is a
beast and and I always felt that was one
of the stronger you know franchises but
it kind of saddened me what what
happened to like NBA Live and as a
person who came up with NBA Live you
know 95 probably being the Heyday King
whatever he's doing it foreign
you know like the NBA Live guys we were
there you know and then you know the
annualization and kind of lack of
quality that I felt I actually did a
presentation on stage about this period
about about the lack of quality of my
beloved Madden with the you know with
the annualization and I can't lie I
still feel like your former franchise
NBA 2K used to wipe the floor with them
um to be honest you know saying so what
are your feelings about EA Sports you
know during your tenure and you yourself
said we had you on for part one you know
focus groups even said like they were
kind of like they hated arrogant
quarterbacks talking back at the time
what is your thoughts on EA Sports and I
don't appreciate and missing MVP
baseball as well you know so what's your
thoughts on EA Sports
I I loved being president of EA Sports I
love the impact it had on uh Sports
Gamers around the world look every year
there would be abuse about something and
we can talk about NBA live in a second
here but one of the things we would
always look at and we would always
treasure this information we would do
research on all of our sports games we
shipped and then try to figure out what
impact they were having on the Real
World of Sports whether it was soccer
whether it was the NFL whether it was
NBA NHL more recently UFC obviously
Tiger Woods Golf all of these things and
and every time that research came back
is that we were introducing Sports the
the sport
to a new generation of Gamers coming
through a new combination of young men
and women that got their first
experience of hockey or American
football or soccer with a controller in
their hand and that then would lead them
to be fans of quote unquote the real
game if you will but we were the entree
we were the on-ramp we were the thing
that all of a sudden you're playing and
FIFA the game formerly known as FIFA yes
yes gold standard this because as we
started building out again this software
as a service live operations we brought
the world of football I'm going to call
it now to life with 15 000 players and
with the ability through Ultimate Team
to to build your own Ultimate Team so
more and more in those later years of
FIFA were we would do research that your
your average 10 or 11 year old that was
playing this game in Peoria Illinois
could tell you what Lithuanian left back
they should have in their team or what
you know Barcelona Reserve player was
coming through that they were going to
get as a bargain to put in their
ultimate team we introduced The World of
Sports
two young people in a way that the World
of Sports couldn't have done it
themselves because it was becoming more
expensive more difficult to attend live
sporting events
um watching it on TV it took too long
but it took about and EA Sports can
still say that to this day and and that
was our goal was to bring that real life
experience so we started moving away
from purely play a simulation of the
game and and go play another one and go
play your friend across the world in
this simulation to building out
experiences around that all the things
we love about sports it's Sunday so the
NFL
you know and so we're and it's not just
the three and a half hours or whatever a
game is it's the lead up who's injured
what happened on Thursday Night Football
what's going to go on uh this coming
Sunday and you get all of the lead-up
shows and and that was our role was
introducing that sport to young men and
women around the world in a way that
they felt comfortable that they could
research wasn't going to take them hours
sat in the living room which they don't
go in anymore and they just and our
research every single year we would use
Warsaw school at University of Oregon
which was a great Sports
business school that would do all the
research for us and that research would
always come back and we took great pride
in that absolutely no I hear you again
it's just I just want to go back to the
Glory Days
but I understand the experience I'll let
you I'll let you know I have I have a
what happened to fight night yeah like
that we got questions
fight night you guys came in and and and
and
like won the fighting because Sega had
uh you know the Champions boxing and
that stuff was great and I that's in our
intro I love those you know Evander
Holyfield boxing and Buster Douglas and
I'm a fan of all of that every fighting
game that ever came out but EA came out
and I remember the year it was Roy Jones
and it was Bernard Hopkins oh my God
that looked amazing looks it to this day
to me is the best looking feeling a
boxing game and still can be played to
this day on your Xbox yes my thing is
was the licensees because from my
understanding you guys had to negotiate
per person for the for to get them into
the game did that become too cumbersome
and you went to the UFC where the UFC is
under one banner and Dana White controls
all of that so you just paid the UFC and
you was able to get the UFC instead of
dealing individually with individual
boxes that inflate their wealth uh was
that the the barrier what was the
barrier it was Floyd being difficult I'm
just joking
how many development Studios and what is
the opportunity cost and where is the
young fight fan where are their heads
and where do we see the future being so
you remember knockout Kings of course
right so then then when I'm there we do
fight night and if you recall Muhammad
Ali versus Mike Tyson yes yeah so but
but King yeah a little bit it is not
easy you've got to deal with the
promoters with the fighters
um it's not the the I don't know what to
say
cleaner sport are you implying that
you're right but it's difficult and it's
difficult but we also because remember
there was an interim step as we decided
that mixed martial arts was going to be
the future and you've got to figure out
like where's the puck going
right and so we said look we've only got
so many studios and our Vancouver Studio
was working on this we made the decision
to develop first EA Sports MMA because
the UFC license at that time yes then
then I remember going to see Dana White
and in in Vegas and and with the Potato
Brothers
yeah I'm just saying look we're in the
market for this and eventually we got it
and that's where UFC came about but
there was the step and and so we could
only do so many things at once and and
you you move your studio and you say
look um to do MMA and then ultimately
with the goal of getting that UFC
license we we just can't do boxing
anymore and the numbers didn't carry it
either you know and so and it was a
period where you yeah you look back but
everybody you mentioned King you know
you had Lennox Lewis to that and Sugar
Ray Leonard and all people that that I
had the pleasure of meeting and working
with up in Vancouver but there were
people in the past and there was nobody
during that period if you remember maybe
the yeah Roy Jones but man you want you
want to go back
Hearns Hagler
yeah but who else I mean exactly is and
look I grew up with Ali versus Frasier
versus and Larry Holmes when when there
was a heavyweight championship fight the
world stopped oh yes yes I stopped right
and then for those for the viewers and
listeners and maybe a little younger go
watch when we were Kings oh that's an
excellent yes yes yes I'm sure you'll
still find it on Netflix but that was
the Golden Era of boxing with and and I
forgot to mention Joe Frazier I mean so
you think about it but I think and
answer your question the moment in time
is we looked at where the world of
boxing was and it just wasn't going to
be attractive enough to our core gamer
um to deliver it and we felt the future
was MMA and ultimately UFC and that's
where we went really quickly for my
brother song because I would it would be
okay so I feel you about to jump in
because I got I want to say you're both
VP and MVP baseball my baseball Brethren
like please yeah I mean MVP baseball
still to this day is one of the greatest
baseball games ever made and then
immediately and then immediately
afterwards you guys jumped to the NCAA
license and then after that it was dead
again I'm assuming the story is kind of
similar to boxing where it's like the
license cost way too much uh the Players
Association stuff in addition to the Mob
license cost way too much and at that
point it kind of seemed like like Sony
was sort of running away with it was was
that sort of the thinking about why they
stepped away from baseball yeah why
y'all relinquish that you've got to do
the
economics on these Sports and again the
opportunity cost and and you're right
Sony had it if you remember the old days
of 989 Sports
right so so you start having first party
exclusives on platforms that you really
can't then get on and so you know we we
love dealing with the MLB and we were
constantly sitting down with MLB and MLB
PA but but it just wasn't working out
economically and what you need to do is
give your Dev team a chance to to hit
the targets and and also it's like where
are this where are the talents of this
Dev team better place and you make hard
decisions and so it just during my
period anyway there it just wasn't
working out that we could get MLB MLB PA
together look at the PlayStation
platform the Xbox platform whatever
Nintendo platform happened to be that we
or wherever at that time and say hey
numbers don't Stack Up unfortunately and
look I I love baseball as well but it
was one of those where uh and obviously
EA is not trying to do something a
little younger with baseball
um so and I wish them the best there but
but it just wouldn't economically stack
up when we looked at license costs we
did the forecasts of units and we looked
at you know in particular the
PlayStation platform we just there was
no room on there so you know because it
was what uh MLB the Show they had
transferred to the show already from um
from 989 they had become you know
certainly San Diego already and they
were doing the show yeah yeah
fortunate but you can only do so much
and we were still doing during that
period Tiger Woods and and it was you
know uh and then golf struggled a little
bit as well and moved to PGA
[Music]
um you know so you you're constantly
unfortunately having to make decisions
you don't want to let your studio go
because they've put their heart and soul
into a game that never really had a
chance of coming out profitably at the
other end and you know that was always
the challenge is you think about the
studio you think about the way you best
deploy them you look at the World of
Sports and you see the future and you go
we're going there not fair enough yeah
and it's fair especially with the lights
I'm sorry sorry didn't say anything one
more question please um so so looking at
these games now they come out on a
yearly Cadence these games these devs
have nine months pretty much to put out
a brand new game every year
um but then you have that fluidity with
the back end stuff with like the
ultimate team and stuff like that
do you do you think some of these games
would be better served as pure services
and where you say hey this is the base
game for this generation and we're gonna
sell you a 40 upgrade every year so as
opposed to selling you a 70 product that
they had to try to when you look at it
on the surface doesn't look that much
different from the previous year my and
just to interject before you answer
Peter um the reason why I think it is
also relevant I I was just interviewing
your beloved turn 10 and and those guys
because of Saki and um Greenwald and
being King were there and this was the
first time Forza Motorsport was actually
so it was going to be live service that
they were going to have this platform
for the generation and iterate upon it
is this something that ever came up in
your meetings as well to add on to what
saw I've asked you
yeah it always came up Less in the
meetings but Gamers were always asking
the question you know why do we need a
full game every year that then iterates
with downloads and updates and live
service we're talking about but I you
know our decision was very much we're
going to deliver and and the way it
works is the dev there's two Dev teams
working here it's not that the dev Team
Works nine months here's the game go
take a break and start on next year you
you've got parallel development teams
working a year out and they're thinking
about not next year's game but the year
after and what um you know what what's
technology going to empower in this and
what does our physics engine look like
and and you know what audio and and what
what is going to be the playlist what
what is it
yeah you're gonna do with you know put
100 songs on the on on the FIFA game
and so from that perspective you're
working in parallel
a your your core team yes they're
working to deliver next year's game but
you've also got a team that's thinking
about the year after and you've got a
team that thinks live operations about
what are we doing tomorrow morning what
what are we going to update here
particularly within ultimate teams which
is not only the game for me known as
FIFA but also in Madden and hockey
obviously
um and that's the way it works but yeah
the question always came up but we just
felt it was best for the game of the
amount of content we had to deliver it
was best just let's get it out there
every year and then iterate on that
particular game that makes sense what
you just said because one year we will
have a different feature that wasn't
carried over to the next year like you
know one year we have the truck stick or
the next year we'll have like this cone
cone Vision yeah yeah and I I remember
saying why can't we have both
yeah but I I understand and that that's
how my stack went and we would pick if
we're going to play Madden well what
year you want to play yeah because what
year you want to play dictates how good
you're going to be yeah yeah now you
need to be on the same year if you're
going to play each other yeah yeah yeah
and the thing you guys got to remember
you add big features like that it's like
the dev team needs to figure out how it
impacts everything else yes right you
know it's so it's it's this ability to
put something in seamlessly that becomes
look you needed two or three things to
talk about I needed to go on stage and
talk about these things yeah on behalf
of the dev team and make big deals with
them because they were big deals but the
dab team's got to figure out how to put
them in there how to make them work make
sure that you put you don't put
something in that impacts everything
else and the game is odd these were
always the challenges we had and these
were these were hundreds of people
working and still up many hundreds of
people working on this so it's no
trivial feat to do what EA and EA Sports
did and continues to do which is these
massive experiences not just the
simulation of the game the entire
experiences that is reflective of The
Real World of Sports yeah no well said
and um you know I definitely also during
your tenure you know kind of the
Resurgence of the single player games
and you know um obviously you see what
EA is doing now I want to shout out our
good friends at uh Patrick Grant at
respawn who we've had on to talk about
Jedi Survivor you know I'm a huge Vince
impeller fan I'm a huge impeller fan and
um you know Vince if you let's think
we'd love to have you in the room before
we go into that yes people in the chat
are asking us I don't know if you can
comment on this but they want to know if
you can comment on anything about visual
Studios and Dead Space
well
visceral okay
um
Dead Space was great you know and and it
had that eeriness
freak me the hell out
you just if you remember it you're like
going around you go what is gonna what's
gonna jump out of here and so and this
is a period where just that time you
know we're getting I I don't know if
it's 4K already by then but we're
certainly getting ultra high def but
more and the Brilliance for me of dead
space was audio was that you know
surround sound of like is it is it
behind me you know so but but in the end
you know and then Dead Space 2 came out
visceral was in our Redwood Shores uh
offices right there in the campus there
but you know I mean I can't I don't know
what the question is I mean it just
didn't work out and and a lot of the
visual team went and did other things
but you know it just that space is one
of those IPS that I'm sure down the road
and look I've I've been gone a few years
for me
but but it's one of those IPS that's
that's sitting there that one day
somebody's gonna go let's give it
another video yeah I hear it the
question I was asking before I asked the
visual was just about
my beloved I love Vincent I felt my
beloved Titanfall too never got that
fair shape either I feel like yeah you
had it so close to Battlefield one and I
feel they kind of cannibalize each other
and it it satis my heart that I wasn't
getting it and I think you were you
around your area during that tenure as
far as I think it was because yeah Mass
Effect was still going on I believe
Andromeda Dragon's Age Titanfall was
kind of around that era I think correct
me if I'm wrong
yeah I I spent I love Vince and Vincent
you know obviously a guy
you know and gone nose to nose with in
those days oh yeah oh yeah Infinity War
yeah and so I would start going down to
LA and and seeing what this Titanfall
thing is
something that we believed in and
um and it was amazing you know it just
was something that um as more and more I
saw of it and we knew we were going to
get behind it which we did big time uh
with the whole thing because we we just
felt good about Vince you feel good
about a team and that you trust the team
and they're innovators and they're
disruptors and they've got that bravado
game's gonna kick ass and
and when you're the publisher you you
only see so much you know in in this and
you go I just believe in Vince and then
you start you get you get inside the
Titan and you go this is a whole
different experience than we've seen
before and then drop in those Titans in
onto the battlefield
um you know it was just amazing and then
I I'd gone by the time that that coup de
gras of Apex Legends comes out
just and that's Classic Events and and
one of the great great innovators uh in
in gaming history uh is Vince sampelo
and his team absolutely real quick I
just want to give I got you guys we'll
give the flowers I completely agree and
in my opinion he's never made a bad game
continue game all right before we move
on
I have one one thing it's just an
observation
when you went over the EA and you know
we got down in I I think Donnie gets a
bad rap honestly you know um I wasn't a
fan of a lot of things because I mean
you're following a great right you walk
out the door you left on a super high
note
boy how can you feel these shoes right
but
when you went over the EA
you made it a little bit more amicable
to work with Microsoft
and Titanfall was there my question is
and you can say no that you wouldn't
answer but um
did you actively say I'm going to listen
because before it was times it felt like
EA really wasn't listening to Microsoft
dealing with Sony and yes sensitive it
to somebody that you are actually with
and you were on a high note and you know
the struggles over there did you give
that sensitive air the Microsoft because
Titanfall became a launch exclusive for
Xbox and that's my question was your air
a little bit more sensitive than
Microsoft knowing the struggles knowing
that they're the Challenger brand
knowing that they're number two
yeah I mean yes and no I mean look my
heart was very much an Xbox but I'm I'm
at that point Chief Operating Officer of
a third-party publisher and so it's it's
yes it's uh Robbie and the team that I'd
left behind and then Phil and Shane Kim
and everybody Jay Allard probably still
around and and uh but also Jack Trenton
and the team over there at um you know
Sony and we need it to be yeah we needed
to make sure that we were delivering on
all the platforms we you can't favor one
I mean there are times you do that but
but the EA situation I mean just to put
put a ribbon around this remember we
were voted worst company in America
you know and and so my view on that you
know the tallest trees catch the most
wind and this was a website called the
consumerist and and it look it was
ridiculous but a lot of it was focused
on the ending of Mass Effect 3. oh boy
y'all
right and it's just
you know and and a little bit of we we
were driving you know a path that hadn't
been walked before of of downloadable
content and microtransactions and moving
towards free to play and always on and
so this was you you know the like the
Pioneers get the houses but yeah
but the settlers get the houses and we
were doing
uh it's probably Politically Incorrect
anymore but from the perspective of what
we were doing we were trailblazing yeah
and we were we were trying to figure out
where this industry was going and we
were unafraid of being the company that
would give it a go as a result you know
the consumerist
um made us and and it was somewhat
laughable but I always remember though
we're in San Francisco and the lead
story on the news that night was uh Bay
Area company voted worst in America and
this was the same year the BP had pretty
much polluted the entire building right
and so
um and it was hard on the employees and
and so we needed to rally and the but
also there was this reflection moment
that we had at EA so I I took on I
developed a program called reputation
Rehabilitation a little bit of it
literally a mouthful but rep rehab we
called it and we go you know what let's
let's take a listen let's look let's
reflect on this because a little bit
were the smoke there may be some fire on
this and we then started to think how
can we how can we engage better with our
with our Gamers and you know so rep
rehab was a very definitive program to
take on board criticism think about how
we engage better with our customer with
the gamer I jumped on started jumping on
Twitter which which David tinson my uh
my head of cards at the time was now the
CMO there so ah you're not going up
Twitter he was too loose there's nothing
to be gained on this but we started to
engage and helping Gamers and talking to
Gamers and this was part of an outreach
program that allowed us to at least
understand what the frustrations were
yeah and this is
a decision of industries that are going
through Mammoth change and companies
that are leading that change and they're
sticking their neck out uh doing things
that now you know everybody does it but
somebody's got to go first and do it and
so we did that concurrently internally I
needed to like get morale back again yes
and so I'm the Chief Operating Officer
and so being a marketer I developed a
team that not only reported to me but
also from all parts of the company and I
called it the engine room and you know
got a logo and and with the Steam on the
Pistons the oil on the way and gears and
and we hauled our way back through the
engine room to be able to get to where
EA got to when I was there and certainly
still is which is a powerful digital
profitable company that Wall Street
Embraces that the eight nine thousand
employees whatever happens to be can
feel good about their jobs and you know
their compensation package and their
Equity is good so they can take care of
their families and get a little bit of
stability and consistency back because
those were rough times very difficult
times but yeah we we did all of that
because we believed in the future but
also uh there was pause for thought and
reflection we started to look at the
tweets and the inbounds that the
customer service was getting so yeah
maybe we can do better no I love it
yeah I love it because it also reminds
me of the Dreamcast days in your focus
group kind of reading the temperature of
the room and the assessment period right
and and it's needed if you're truly
going to improve and reflect it and I
love that you guys did that during the
height of the storm because it can't
feel good internally right so you I love
the I love the the verbiage of rehab
like that that's really cool like to
really put that out there so salute to
you kudos to the team you guys ushered a
tremendous era right then they're in EA
and I definitely want to give you a
flowers there because again trailblazing
doing things that people may be scared
of but this is where the industry is
going that inevitability and it's really
cool to see I know we're going to get
into Liverpool but I I want to skip
ahead just slightly because you know I
don't feel people talk about your tenure
at Unity a lot and and and what I feel
is like your name wasn't senior vice
president and a GM of unity Sports and
live entertainment and what did that
entail and then also last time you
mentioned that you wanted to talk about
volumetric capture and and what just
tell us about that whole tenure
well when I left Liverpool you know
we'll talk about Liverpool we're gonna
say that for last
um John riccatello reached out he saw
that I was leaving Liverpool and and
reached out to me and again at this
point I've known John since gosh since
1999 when I joined Sega and just EA
didn't develop for the Dreamcast
platforms
we've either competed against each other
we've collaborated during the Xbox and
and you know then of course I work for
him at EA and then he went off and and
uh uh did a little bit of work in
Venture Capital elevation partners with
Bono of YouTube but then came back into
the industry with unity and so he said
look we're we're working on volumetric
capture be and and real-time 3D and the
creation of experiences outside of the
gaming world that we think
um you know can be useful and applied
and he says when I think Sports I think
you and so I came in knowing nothing
what he was talking about but very
quickly saw this opportunity
which is different than motion capture
so let's get the terminology right mocap
you're wearing your your neoprene suit
with your mom
and you're seeing the articulation of
the body that can then be interpreted in
simple terms into a wireframe that's
then skinned to look like an avatar are
an athlete whatever happens to be
volumetric capture is actually massive
camera arrays that are capturing data in
real time of body movement and then
going into what's called a solved
solution and then spitting out after a
while that takes a lot of computing
power the actual visual again that you
can then manipulate and work with so
um in three dimensions and what we call
you know nine points of Freedom here of
the movement three-dimensionally and so
when I got there a small team of six
which ended up by the time I left in in
earlier uh in January this year There
Was 80 of us and we developed something
called metacast which was very much
looking at the future of sports and how
you would interact with sports so and
this will happen there's no doubt in my
mind in that let's say World Cup 2026
here in North America the you watch a
goal being scored and you go to your
phone or your your tablet 10 15 seconds
later and you then drop yourself into
the penalty area right behind the player
and then you spin around looking at what
that player is doing as if you're in the
Penalty Box
The Tackle made it's controversial is it
a penalty you've got these nine degrees
that you get nine points of Freedom that
you can look at here
um so from that perspective and have
incredibly talented team wow Adam my
hill in particular who had developed
cynical Center machines so these ways of
visualizing data in in its early years
so camera and lighting with this key but
we developed this thing called metacast
concurrently I was also doing live
entertainment which coming out of covid
there was the belief and still is that
we're gonna go and have concert
experiences without having to go through
this
Arena and so we worked through that and
we were very fortunate to uh get a
client Insomniac who do EDM and they
focused on EDC in in Las Vegas and
Orlando and all the places did it and
started working on this virtual
experience that you could be part of
electric Daisy and then have this EDM
experience which are massive uh if
you've ever been to one I was fortunate
a couple of times in Vegas and so the
virtualization of the live entertainment
thing but yeah I got my iPad here as I'm
talking I may be able to show you what
I'm talking about wait let's go you know
keep we can uh yeah I'll talk while you
pull it up because it kind of reminds me
of my work at Meadow with um when they
have Horizon and basically watching the
NBA games like live on Courtside where
the VR headset and and and just
different events that will kind of put
you into the heart of it you like you
can reach out and touch of it yes on the
NFL have something kind of like that
um because when I had the package you
were able to view the tackle from
different angles like because they had
this camera that would run the length of
the field and it was like the eye in the
sky and you would be able to like zoom
in
and I understand what you're talking
about is a little bit way more in depth
you know way more in depth but yeah we
were able to see the play from different
angles and get low in the field and that
I missed that part from Xbox one that
passed through and all that other stuff
that was implemented but it was good
features that were there yeah this demo
is going to take too long but we're
talking about King is called the spider
Cam and so that takes you right down but
but what we're talking about is you
could be under Center literally drop
yourself there because the camera
systems of stadiums of the future
there'll be hundreds of them that are
cut not just capturing video or visuals
or film they're capturing data and then
reconstituting that data as interactive
experiences that you can touch and spin
that player you want to see if a
receiver's root as if you're the
cornerback and that is so that's the
work that I did at Unity uh we did
metacast and then Unity show which which
is a platform which allows promoters and
and even artists themselves to develop
these kind of interactive experiences
where you can sit at home and and have
fun watching a concert concerts as we
know are are not cheap anymore
so I mean the ability ability for you to
have a 20 experience I mean look at
Taylor Swift tickets and just
you know a few weekends ago my wife and
I in Vegas we saw a Dell on Friday night
we saw the B-52s on Saturday night
saw queen bee herself Beyonce on Sunday
oh the queen
I'll tell you what that cost yeah
I I like the only thing I liked about
covet is the VR experience that I have
uh you know I had my uh Oculus uh Quest
too and I put it on and I'm able to be
at a UFC fight ringside or I'm able to
be at a concert and look over and see
people
um that ability to be in the comfort of
your home and to still experience the
live uh event and for a fraction of the
cost because I understand you physically
being there of course astronomical and
me virtually being there of course the
fraction of the cost or whatever it is
and I I honestly believe that's exactly
where entertainment is going uh to reach
more masses so you know Unity is on the
right track to be honest with you yeah
yeah I know and we're proud of the work
we did look live entertainment and
sports are becoming exclusive and
Technology needs to make them inclusive
where you can't get there I mean we'll
talk about Liverpool one of the things
that was very clear to me when I got
there we probably have 300 million fans
around the world I mean just
at the very minimum that put the hand up
and say I'm a Liverpool fan I bet 99.5
of those fans will never see Liverpool
live I mean that that and it's both a
shame but it's the fact of life when you
become a global yes uh entity as
Liverpool is and and you know Manchester
United and these massive clubs that have
got multi-generational support that goes
back from the 60s and 70s and this TV
started to become part of the way you'd
experience it because when I grew up in
England there was no live sports on
television right because it their
business model was very much you go to
the stadium and you push a couple of
pounds through the turnstile because
it's a business model based on
attendance yes right not engagement and
so things changed radically but that was
and and again you know at Liverpool I
learned and took to me with me so many
lessons I'd learned in video games about
engagement that was critical well said
well said I love what would you say I
love what you were doing there you know
I do feel that is the future as far as
you know 3D and sports and entertainment
and getting that virtual experience that
really cool Tech I do have one last
question because I know we got to get
Liverpool next but I do have one last
Community question and it's a tough one
because I do have to ask you because I
know what you're doing is kind of
separate you know saying from kind of
like Unity developing in a game and
working with that but um with everything
that's going on right now you know
obviously there's a strong developer
pushback in the community on this latest
Unity runtime free you know what are
your thoughts on that and then obviously
the latest Amendment slash apology you
know that was sent out by unity to the
deaf community
trying to make things good Mark Wood
and psychology out and he led up with
I'm sorry and there's a lot of
amendments to your point to the runtime
fees and whether it was going to be
retroactive and going forward here look
yeah I love working at Unity there are 8
000 very Talent talented hard-working
people there
um and what we have to remember and
whether we like it or not they're a
publicly traded company that has only
made a profit in one quarter of their
public existence and they have invested
hundreds of Millions if not billions of
dollars in building out the unity
platform and engine and at some point
for them to be sustainable and to
continue
um they've got to find ways to make
money uh that are consistent and and
material maybe this wasn't the right way
and maybe there should have been a lot
more listening and consensus building
and what have you and I think Mark in
his apology
um you know outline that we should have
listened better we should have sat down
with our in particular our Indie
developers to understand what impact
with this on this but but ultimately
this is a company that's invested not
only in gaming but in real time 3D
automotive design and engineering and
architecture they're using their game
engine platform to bring things to life
in different Industries and where video
games can can actually enhance all the
things that we use outside of gaming and
in particular go talk to the automotive
designers now that we're used to doing
things in clay which always seemed
ridiculous
you know whether they to your point King
put their VR helmet on and they're
designing the cockpit and and the
ergonomics of their BMWs and their Audis
and their Mercedes in real time and and
that's a video game engine doing it for
them so
um you know Unity just needs to figure
out what the next three four five years
look like and how they're going to be
sustainable and and how they are going
to be able to have a positive impact on
our industry continue to support Indie
developers yes you know the the unity
engine by far the majority of
independent developers Unity absolutely
because it was cost effective and
efficient I mean I know it has its
critics but you know if it's not this
it's got to be something else they've
got to figure out how they without
impacting negatively the business model
of the independent developers how they
can actually
I agree so that they can keep everybody
employed and keep Unity going no well
said well said first of all respect your
transparency there this video you know I
love our fajito Dodge nothing he he
about it that's why I love you
Liverpool's in the building so we're
here for the main event that's what we
say the last one that's right and look
I'm just like so amazed by this because
this is one of the coolest parts of your
journey in my opinion right you know the
pride of Liverpool coming back home
CEO of his whole town Club so despite
giving me my first love I think this has
to be one of your greatest Milestones
like this is a bit of course the success
you have there you will never walk alone
so let's talk about it how did all of
this go down
well it it's again
I need your black book there
I knew he was gonna say a recruiter yeah
these guys keep showing up so they call
and um trying to think exactly when it
was it was probably late 2016 in the
fall of 2016. and uh I get a call and
and you know people that have been
fortunate enough to have some Career
Success are constantly getting pinged
you know there's a role here and what
have you and so I get a call from a
recruiter Spencer Stewart one of the
biggest Recruiters in the world and it's
it's their London office and they go hey
um would you ever consider moving back
to England again and I always remember
I'm in my office of the year I'm working
out the sun is shining
and I love EA and I'm about to enter my
10th year at Electronic Arts and you
know the stocks back to 102 twenty five
hundred and thirty and we are firing on
also
Peter almost said you have a nice day
sir I mean the paycheck was was nice
exit the weather is nice let's go you
gotta blow it up when it's good
well that's it
that's it
and the recruiter says well what if it
was to be Chief Executive Officer of
Liverpool Football Club
did your heart stop
there might have been a pause on the
line at that moment and so you've got to
my dad first took me to watch Liverpool
in 1959. and I went to see Liverpool
versus Leighton Orient Liverpool 143
Adam field that was four years of age
and I was submit and like you know
appeared in Liverpool at that period
you're either red or you're blue yeah
it's beautiful or your Everton there's
there's nowhere in between
and my grandad's team so this goes back
family
1920s 1930s and you know and so I I gave
it some thought a lot of thought and and
uh my wife Debbie who California girl
and never lived in Liverpool and I
and I
I it was gut wrenching to make the
decision to leave a and I will never
forget what had happened is we we came
to an agreement
but I wanted to see through uh q1 or or
actually you know the the final yeah it
would be q1 calendar 2017 Q3 fiscal for
EA because it was getting to the end of
the fiscal year and I wanted to make
sure that uh I just wasn't walking away
and also there was a timing issue at
Liverpool
um and so I agreed I think in January to
to the contract and then we had actually
an April date that I was going to uh
announce I was leaving at the end of the
quarter and everything would be smooth
and the transition would be great
the call on the morning of February 28th
uh in 2017 at about 5 a.m and it's my
new bosses Fenway Sports Group or on the
Boston Red Sox and it says hey we got a
problem a newspaper uh in in England and
a newspaper that I will never talk about
that uh is a rag of immense proportions
that you're going to be the new CEO and
they're going to run that story at 10
o'clock tonight on their online uh
portal and because I'm a section 16
officer of a publicly traded company
that's got an impact yeah
so so I had to then resign or make the
company aware that this story is coming
out and that I was going to be leaving
EA and a moment again I never will
forget so it's I go to work and it's
like 7 30 in the morning and I call
Andrew Wilson my boss
and Andrew uh is at breakfast I said he
said I Andrew I need to meet we you know
when you're coming in and say well I'm
going to breakfast a lunch breakfast
meeting what's going on I said well I I
don't want to do this over the phone
but I need to tell you I'm going to
leave EA
and there's a pause he's driving there's
a pause and
um he says where you going you're going
to another publisher what are you doing
I said well
I'm going to be the new CEO at Liverpool
Football Club
and then there's a longer pause yeah
he's like I can't compete with that
no but better than that and and his
voice starts breaking and he says mate I
I couldn't be more happy for you oh I'm
sad for us I couldn't be more happy for
you right and I know what this means to
you and uh I said yeah I mean Andrew the
only place you know this is the only job
that I would take on the VA and uh we
then scrambled because we had to
announce at the close of the Bell that I
was gonna be leaving and he wrote what's
known as an EA action which is a
announcement to the entire company that
was wonderful he's a Chelsea fan so he
got it yeah
again you always remember and and I
always tell everybody you're remembered
by how you leave yes
so always when you leave a company
that's all people remember if you leave
angry throwing grenades
you know talking about people in a
negative way on the way out and and and
being bitter uh you know that's how
people remember you so I always say You
Remember by how you leave and so I I
then work for another couple of months
and we got everything in place and got
my team in place in a succession plan
and then left um jumped on a plane uh
with Debbie and seven suitcases and a
great day uh and uh headed to Liverpool
um and
started work almost immediately uh
getting ready for the
2017-2018. I bet you I bet you at the
end of the day he's like you know what I
hate to lose Peter but at least he ain't
going to the competition
because you can hear the fear the
trepidation like what what competitive
Activision yeah there's nowhere else I
would go in the industry
but this was special to me look my my
dad imbued this love of the club my dad
has You'll Never Walk Alone on his
gravestone I mean just the whole element
of what the club means and what it's
what has given so many people in a city
that's had some really tough times but
we always had football and we always had
we always had uh the ability to be able
to
um look forward to three o'clock on a
Saturday afternoon when the games used
to be played because whatever tough
times we were going through we we would
have this that we could forward to and
fortunately you know it's it's a great
club with a great history that's won a
lot of trophies and brought a lot of joy
to people yeah you brought success there
two quick questions regarding Liverpool
that I have to ask for my our website
laws of gaming.net our editor-in-chief
about mood he big Liverpool fan and he
says um did anyone from the squad
recognize you from your gaming career
and geek out in front of you and then
the second question is from uh added
another editor at Lords of gaming.net
daddy it for the ammo he says he's a
huge LFC fan he said Peter we won our
First Premier League trophy under your
tenure the one question I'd like to know
is if he had to choose anything specific
what made the difference in that in your
opinion was it the manager klopp a
certain player you signed or something
else so did people geek out and then
about the Premier League trophy
I don't know if they geeked out but uh
people might remember Jordan Henderson
the Liverpool Captain been on the cover
of FIFA
and I may or may not have had a lot oh
you you made
I think that he that was the Champions
Edition listen I okay so you really
stole my question that was that was I
was doing some real research last night
so you already stole my question
when you play in the game
and you playing your team oh come on
amazing because I know you were sitting
I'm running out I'm gonna win I'm gonna
do this but now you got the actual shot
this this one way I mean I could sit
there and play the Jets all day long you
know no Recruiters in my DM but if they
ever gave me the recruiting job then you
want to be the the you know the CEO of
the Jets and my thoughts on actually
winning now you have the opportunity to
do so did you say oh hell yeah we going
and they're gonna do it under my 10 year
you could say all you like but actually
delivering and look I I very clear I ran
the business of football uh and left
Jurgen klopp and his team okay to to do
everything they needed to do on the
pitch it was my job and more importantly
the 800 people that work for the club
that didn't kick a ball uh to provide
everything the the the the financial
support to to be able to buy the great
players uh the uh the logistics to make
sure that all they had to worry about
was winning on a Saturday or a Sunday or
a Tuesday or a Wednesday you know
champions league and building the club
and getting closer to our fans and one
of the things that I did uh very
controversially and upon reflection you
know took some risks and did some stupid
things was was get engaged on Twitter
with our fans which many if not most
premier league CEOs would never dream of
doing and and you know ownership was not
a fan of this but I felt being a liver
puddly and living in Liverpool and what
was needed they were kind of what we
call absentee owners they didn't live
there they would come over for games
from time to time but I felt rightly or
wrongly that we needed to engage
Liverpool as a city and liver pudlians
as a people are a warm group of people
that that circle the wagons around that
City and take great pride in in who they
are there's a there's an expression I'm
scouse not English is it's the people
of Liverpool and so and football is
absolutely core yes for that entity and
that belief and look these are people in
in a large part that don't have a lot
going for them that have been much
maligned over decades from from the
British government and and you know go
don't mention Margaret Thatcher's name
so you've got you've got this concept of
of we'll we'll get by ourselves we don't
need your help and so and football was
an important part the crutch that
allowed people to be able to do that so
um yeah I mean when I think of what
needed to be done and the look I was I
was I'd rather be lucky than good
and Jurgen was building
a squad that was capable as we were by
the second end of the second season the
best team in the world and
actually go into Qatar to Doha and be
becoming FIFA Club World Champions as we
did uh as I'm fond of saying we became
champions of everything and everywhere
because we won the Champions League we
won the Premier League
when the super cup which is Europe
European Champions together and then
eventually won the FIFA Club World Cup
and so anything we could win we had won
and um
as regards scoring goals or clearing
balls off the line uh it was everything
to do with that team but my job was to
have my very talented people there in
Liverpool and around the world making
sure that Jurgen and the team had
nothing to worry about except putting
the ball in the back of the net oh man
that's a huge part though that part
right there no distractions no cares you
just go play I'll handle everything else
yeah and that's what we do that that's
that allowed people to succeed yeah I
mean I mean your track record speaks for
itself
we can't we can't avoid the fact that
everywhere you go you live in better
situations
yeah look I mean it's a beautiful thing
and and again so I wanted to say that
one for last because I know we had time
but it's one of those things where it's
like the Conquering Hero he returns home
you know and then you have this magical
story and as a person who is very
fortunate I have a good friend of mine
shout out to Lord Greg who is the
biggest Liverpool fan remember I'm an
American kid well I know it's football
you know I know it's American football
you know what I'm saying like so he's
like you have to come with me and I
remember getting on that plane I go to
England and then I jump on some train
and it was a long ride and I get to
Liverpool and to your point yeah you can
tell the climate was different right the
energy was different but I remember
walking into anfield I still have the
video I'll send this to you Lord Peter
and I will tell you right now
when they we were playing you guys are
playing Hull
and you guys win the game but during
yeah yeah it was oh the whole hole was
outside Airfield it was it was a thing
right and I think you guys had Suarez at
the time it was a big thing whatever
right and I get there and I don't know
what I'm what's what's about to happen
King and you hear a whole stadium
singing this song of you will never walk
it is the most emotional magical thing
I've I I pulled out my phone I have it
till this day and recorded I'm like what
is happening this is Magic right now and
I have to admit there was no energy in
any sport that I've ever encountered
that matched that energy it was amazing
so I have photos I have pictures it was
so cool to go to my first game you know
and it was it was Liverpool and again so
I know what it means you know to the
people and and how you guys take so much
pride in that and salute to you for
bringing home the trophy and all that
good stuff and you know I guess all the
the final things where we get you out of
here is um you know obviously you know
you did that you're back home right I'm
assuming lady Debbie's happy birthday
you know what I'm saying you got a
little you got some sky going on so
Santa Barbara Sky so yeah talk to me
about that before
we came back you know we had um we had
seen if I didn't already know the impact
that that football can have on people on
community on on people with
disadvantaged situations but it gave
them hope and I think and Debbie would
tell you this we we had won the
Champions League in in Madrid uh on June
1st we beat Spurs two nil we we partied
all night long in the hotel and we jump
on the team playing uh the next morning
at six a.m We didn't go to bed and we'd
go back we leave 50 60 000 of our fans
in Madrid we fly back to Liverpool the
next morning and we all go shower at the
training ground and then the buses open
top buses arrive because we're gonna go
through the streets of Liverpool with
the Champions League trophy and I was in
one of those moments that that you will
never forget they said you know get on
the bus and it's like you know I didn't
do anything here but I got on the bus
with the team with Van Dyke with
Muhammad obviously Jurgen and we set off
what turned out to be a four-hour
journey through 750
000 people wow from start to finish of
showing them the trophy and Debbie was
on the bus behind and again from from
her perspective she'd never experienced
anything like this but you're driving
through in Liverpool Kensington
Islington to Brooks some of the most
disadvantaged
in all of Britain that's what I noticed
yep in all of Britain and you're driving
and and we are showing them the trophy
and the tears you can sometimes see and
people poverty and by that and I don't
mean to be disrespectful but you can see
in their faces and their body language
and their demeanor these are people that
that just haven't had a fair Shake in
life and have grown up in tough
circumstances
but they had Liverpool Football
that allowed them to be part of
something bigger than they were ever
going to get in their real life which is
a tough life and as we're showing them
Trophy and leaning over the bus you see
this the grown man crying and just
because this means so much to them then
we ended up and and what I did as well
is I have a picture of my dad on the on
my phone and and I was able and my dad
had been gone 20 years and I was able to
show Dad nice what was going on so we
had that but we ended up on the
Liverpool Waterfront where there were a
quarter of a million people we left most
of our rabid fans back in Madrid they
could get back but it was spectacular
and only then
do you realize what the impact of this
game is so concurrently you know I've
been lucky in life EA had been good to
me financially so when we went to
Liverpool we formed our own charitable
Foundation the beautiful foundation and
we focused on food banks because
one in five families in Liverpool
couldn't put food on the table at night
and needed food bank and so we focused
on that my mom was a nurse at all the
hay Children's Hospital post-world War
II and and so we funded treatment rooms
for for children that were burned
victims and that needed to come in and
get special treatment
um cancer horrifically in the north of
England
50 percent of people will get cancer uh
before they die and it's an unbelievable
number that's a little lifestyle driven
um but but when you get into
disadvantaged communities cancer rates
arrays and that's and that's the way it
is around the world so supporting cancer
hospital is what we do so fast forward
to coming back to Santa Barbara and we
still do that in fact we're going over
at the end of next week uh I'm speaking
in Belgium on football management but
then going to Liverpool to support these
Charities the the second week in October
but then coming back to Santa Barbara we
wanted to do something there's no
professional sports team in Santa
Barbara and soccer as we all know is
exploding right now and just decided
that I'm going to fund uh the new uh
Santa Barbara Sky which is a name we
selected and we're going to be playing
in USL League one uh you know and and
something again giving back and
concurrently we've formed a foundation
that even before we kick a ball we have
a charitable foundation called fundiasi
and Cielo the sky Foundation that's
probably going to spend most of its time
looking at disadvantaged families here
in Santa Barbara because any affluent
community and I don't care how much
money there is is often there's an
engine room back there of people that
that mow The Lawns and clean the streets
and serve in restaurants and we have
that here and and they have a tough time
as well so that's a little bit of the
foundation of Santa Barbara Sky and I'm
very proud uh Debbie and I are very
proud to be the the founding owners
awesome that that's that was going to be
my question because
um last night when I was doing the
research I didn't know that I didn't
know that you started the foundation and
you know the cancer or researching to
get back and my question was what like
spark that fire in you to do that and
you answered that question you know
going through the ride through Liverpool
and and you know showing your father and
I'm I'm no that moment that he took you
to see the game and he planted that seed
inside of you and you had that burning
fire since then all the way to lead you
to the point of giving back the
philanthropy that you are doing and the
foundation I just wanted to commend you
on that because doing that I said wow
this man had this meteoric rise and
every place that he did leave he left in
better condition than he got there and
the huge impact that you have made I
know this will be tremendously
successful I understand that to be
because I know your passion lies in this
right here so it was just that rise to
get to this spot that that you are right
now so it was just uh something that eye
opening and you answered the question so
I was going to lead to that question
here but you answered it already so
thank you so much yeah my pleasure and
look you know you've you follow your
dreams and and it's it's a cliche way
but you know things open up when you
work hard and you believe in things and
I've been very fortunate a lot of you
know Crossroads in my life and making
the right decision as it turned out has
been that way you've got to then
um you know I have a TED Talk that I did
a number of years ago that you'll find
that's all right the the you know
basically I finish with you know embrace
your embrace the tree the boy because
from there the Bowers that support you
with who you are and and I've always
learned very heavily on being born in
Liverpool growing up in a pub being a
fish physical education teacher these
are the things that informed my my
career nothing to do with going to
Executive business courses but that
school of reality and hard knocks and
and watching your parents strive and
then you know believing in yourself to
be an immigrant as I am and come to this
country and struggle for a couple of
years
um and and I can look back at you know
having made a difference and that's when
we leave this planet you know that's the
way that you want to think about what
you've done in your life not how much
money you made or you know how big your
house and your cars are but what impact
you've had on other people and their
lives and maybe you know a generation
after you're gone because of what you've
done for them or or how you've inspired
them are in a better place as a result
well said brother this is tremendous I
mean I'm so glad we got to get through
these chapters with you and the journey
like you said the impact you made you
know I just love hearing that especially
again you know being fortunate to visit
Liverpool and I'm glad you said about
you know the conditions and I some of my
cool coolest friends are from Liverpool
and I I said to that Spirit right it's
so it's so damn cool so again we're
gonna get you out of here because you
give us so much time and we really
respect it we do a tradition that we
have with all the guests of the realm on
their exit
um it's kind of funny no pressure but uh
top five video games or franchises of
all time no pressure what it means to
you
oh okay so these are my personal stuff
and the impact
um well I think
I hate to start with two Shooters but
Halo and Gears of War
two things that that I personally got
behind heavily including tattoos
um
you know those two
um huge impact on the Xbox platform
I was so fortunate to be uh interesting
Andrew Wilson was running FIFA at that
time but to be there as we
went up against Pro Evo soccer had the
courage to change the engine uh to move
to a new engine in 2008 and and all of
the downside of that so that we could
hit the ground running and get that big
hockey stick bounce sorry
now you're good
back you know Sonic has always been
and then some of the wackiest stuff
right I mean I I I still think back of
the Sega days of things like c-man and I
think of the dead of the Dead yeah if
anybody remembers typing of the dead and
and Crazy Taxi yeah
a how we used to in those days pay Pizza
Hut on KFC to be in the game right we
actually paid them to be in the game now
they pay you absolutely
uh you know and two of my daughters work
for EA and and I'm very proud of that
and you know one of them you know she
does in-game product placement and
sponsorship and advertising and and
every time I talk to her about it the
amount of money she's talking about for
brands that want to be in games because
they know the exactly games have so that
would be my um
the last one is the Sega collection
right so I'll give you the second
collection first one was Halo gears then
we went to uh FIFA and we had Sonic and
the last time was like a crazy tax he
got Crazy Taxi
and King let's not forget somebody amigo
oh yes I had the Maracas
that that was one of the best
peripherals I mean outside of a gun for
you know uh you know uh yeah
I see the moves I see them with the
moves
like the pose they gotta bring it back
strike the pose
how can you not like a monkey in a
sombrero and Marathi
it reminds me of a Super Monkey Ball
Super Monkey Ball classic my favorite
games too and the final game question
which is tradition I think I know the
answer to this me too
but we got to be fair and unbiased Lord
Peter's favorite console of all time and
why
well it
it Dreamcast
because because it plays the trail and
he plays the trail under tough
circumstances where people at the time
didn't trust Sega felt burned by Sager
they they believed in the PlayStation
the PlayStation 2 was coming but little
Plucky Sager and very talented people
around the world particularly my team in
downtown San Francisco we believed in
the Dreamcast and whilst we we didn't
see it through to where we wanted it to
its Legacy remains to this day and there
are Fingerprints of what the Dreamcast
did on every game and every piece of
hardware and everything somewhere along
the line the Dreamcast informed some of
that and so many developers were making
games today
makes me feel old but with teenagers
playing Sega Dreamcast and fell in love
with video games as a result factual the
legend that is Peter War thank you so
much for all the time you've blessed us
with thank you for the part two we
learned so much man we learned so much
from you and and again the the
competitive nature the Challenger brand
the Showmanship the Forward Thinking the
educator you know it it's just it's it's
really a pleasure to to get insight you
know one of the reasons why we started
iron World podcast is to give flowers to
those in the industry because sometimes
this game is we think we know what's
what's going on but we don't we know you
know and it's good to have your Insight
and um again you know thank you so much
let's get get our outros for the legend
Lord addict you want to say outro for
the legend that is uh Lord petermore
I want to appreciate you coming on Peter
especially during a hurricane you know
it couldn't have been me the moment they
talk about hurricane I'm like oh yeah
I'm out we'll talk to you next week that
man drove through a hurricane
water and wind speed do not mix with me
okay uh you know and I want to thank you
you know personally because it's like I
said last time you hear you know the
360. like I love the you know the series
X Generation the Xbox one generation
it's where I met most of these guys the
360 generation that's probably what made
me like Roots into gaming so yeah I
really want to appreciate that no doubt
Lord solve outros to the legendary
Peterborough
yeah Peter thank you for coming through
apologies for not speaking more I'm just
coughing into the into the microphone
but um but yeah I honestly what's what
I've seen about you and your journey is
that I love the fact that you you're a
person who sort of you're humble but at
the same time you have this expertise
and bravado uh when it comes to selling
a product that you're passionate about
working for a company that you're
passionate about and then you have a
heart behind it too and you understand
you know all the hard work and effort
and that people put into these products
and I just love the fact that you're
you're you're somebody at the highest
levels of management who understands
that as well and is able to sort of
balance those two things and see
see the people that create the product
and the people that love the product for
for for who they are and I just love
that so uh you can sell me anything any
day of the week I will buy it it does
not matter it does not but we end
feeders behind it no no questions to ask
so thank you so much for joining us
again I appreciate you thank you Lord
King outro to the legend feed them off
the the first interview I did video uh
reference on you I was watching a lot of
interviews and and I walked away knowing
stuff but
I didn't I said when I see him you know
I had references right so then we did
the interview and the interview was
absolutely amazing yes and everybody was
talking about it and it was like this
guy is super interesting and this is the
reason why we do this right
um I never thought in a million years I
get a chance to interview you or have a
conversation with you so I was super
pleased on that on the efforts of Laura
Cognito and Lord Attic in the background
these guys work tremendously hard and uh
our wish was always to have that
conversation with you uh you was
probably at that point um no you were at
that point our greatest CEO at Xbox and
you went over to EA and you did your
stuff there and we didn't follow the
journey as much and as intensely as we
should have after you you know left Xbox
and went to EA
uh then last night I'm doing my research
because my wife was like what are you
doing what's up but he's still up for
I'm like yeah we got Peter tomorrow and
um I just I got I gotta dig deeper I
can't do the surface stuff on the video
get deeper went to your Wikipedia I
don't ever go to anybody's Wikipedia but
I'm in here Wikipedia and I'm looking
I'm clicking reference I'm like oh my
God this guy's super amazing right and
then it got to the foundation
and I was like wow
all of this
and he got to here I said this is my
question how did he get to here right
and it just hearing a story I'm like
your father took you to the game because
we didn't get that the first time we got
that this time and this is the reason
why part two is so important the father
took you to the game and you took it
your phone out with a picture of your
father so your father could see it and I
know he's like super proud and your
grandpops are super proud of your
lineage is super proud
it's just it's giving me goosebumps
thinking about it now and you got to the
end of the the ride the four hour ride
you said I gotta give back so God put
you in that place you know whatever you
believe in put you in that place to see
that journey to see exactly what you
meant and what everything means to that
point and you decided to give back and
it's a beautiful thing I just want to
say thank you for being exactly who you
are and being at the right place at the
right time always and I just envy your
email I would like the recruiters
we need we need the black book we need
the black book man out of salute to you
and I'll leave you I'll let you end it
off Peter as you go into your day you
know what food for thought would you
like to leave the industry with as far
as you know obviously you're a person to
always talk about remember from Once We
Came you know obviously you're Forward
Thinking and we all agree that gaming is
the preeminent entertainment medium so
as we move forward into this next era
what food for thought would you like to
leave our audience and just the culture
in general
particularly when you get to my age and
you've had the experiences that I'm
fortunate to have you have an obligation
to give back and talk about this I'm
doing my autobiography so I'm going to
capture a lot of this so that you know
100 years from now my
great-grandchildren will be going how do
we get to Santa Barbara
who brought us over here
happened and so this is what and I think
everybody has a book in them I've always
thought that that the story and it's one
of the little frustrations when I moved
back to Liverpool I've been gone for 50
plus years and I try to piece together
my history of moving back there and
because my mum and dad didn't talk about
it a lot they were more focused on on
taking care of us and running the pub
and and so I think it's important that
you do give back and you have sessions
like this and you guys perform an
unbelievable service to to the gaming
industry to get me and people like me a
platform to talk about this a lot of a
lot of people watching and listening
right now probably weren't even born
when we were launching the Dreamcast and
they need to understand how tough times
were during that period and what we had
to do you know Congress hated us yes if
you remember I mean the British tabloids
used to call it PlayStation killer
and this was this was what we had to
fight was that if you were playing
particularly a shooter you know like a
Call of Duty that the tabloids would say
you have a greater propensity to commit
violent crime yes yes
and we as an industry had to do research
because that's ridiculous and in fact if
you're a gamer during this period your
decision making your concept of strategy
your reactions your use of Technology
how you do things will be superior than
somebody who actually doesn't play games
so right at least with the battles we
had to fight and win during this period
um to to a get respect and B to build
what is now you know a 200 billion
dollar industry should all be proud of
so so yeah and I want to thank you uh
for for allowing me a couple of two and
a quarter hours
and then
one little personal shout out I'm about
to uh yeah I got my stepson Brody who
lives here he's about to be a UCSB
Gaucho this afternoon
and uh he is a dungeon master of the
highest gross so dungeon dragons will be
hitting uh the UCSB campus I'm sure
starting tonight
he is going to take his uh gaming pillow
from Valeri with him oh salute valari
below
keyboard works on that pillow I think it
does and then we'll be good to go so so
shout out to Brody good luck being a
UCSB Gaucho and go DND go do your dig I
love it again thank you
been up last night this has been a blast
thank you enjoy your day and again thank
you for all you do and it's an I've been
an absolute pleasure and an honor to
interview you enjoy your day twice we
did it right two times
You'll Never Walk Alone I got it I could
I could die down this is my greatest
interview
all right thank you brother
all right bye bye-bye what's up you want
to do
um the sponsor uh before we get to the
super chats I mean we could talk about
it we're powered up what we doing
I'm gonna do the um the other sponsor
first let's see if we can do the whole
talk about the powered up because that's
different yeah that's different that's
uh
um let's do the super chances not that
many yeah okay and then and we'll do the
sponsor and then we'll get into our
other uh spot into our other more deeper
conversations
um yeah so forgive me I'm gonna be it's
rough going today that's good I
appreciate you
we got uh Hollywood rules five dollar
Super Chat happy Sunday my NYC West
Virginia cousins thanks again for
getting the great Peter [__] sorry I've
been M.I.A but my football Sundays are
precious get em King
we appreciate you still showing up shout
out to you bro appreciate it yeah you
know you can't watch both yeah you got
that screen open at the center I love
when Xbox one was able to oh that's what
facts and the NFL app on the other side
too yeah oh God it brought everything to
FPS but that's fine
on your television you know I use that
frame rate boost in real life it's not
supposed to look like that kid
oh yeah
Hollywood rules two dollars Super Chat
just thanking the great Peter Moore
hashtag Sega hashtag Xbox yes
lovely lovely human being for real
um then we got Sith Lord remember for 14
months Lord bronze thank you Peter Moore
for everything you've done for Xbox and
Sega I appreciate it very much and I
think you're a great role model for
business yes absolutely
we got fresh dude five nineteen three
one zero two dollars
King what's the name of those Shades I
want them
oh these are um wait hold on these are
we doing what we doing these are my
gazelles oh these gazelles gazelles you
just go right there to any prescription
store to get the real casellis don't go
to these little boots
you you get something with a big gold on
the side just don't go to your
prescription store and um go pick them
up you don't have to change the frames
or whatever they sell it to you straight
up no doubt don't don't go to Canal
Street
no doubt then we have Doctor Strange
Love oh
I'm hungry for some nice juicy thick
Lord Cognito steaks with a nice load of
truffle butter all over the beach oh man
the bit the music please okay
hey hey hey hey hey hey
back to you
shout out to chest congestion
there we got pragmatic Eagle member for
46 months Lord gold I know y'all aren't
quite there just yet but I wanted to be
one of the first to congratulate you
four gentlemen on reaching 20K Subs
here's looking to the next 20K and
Beyond salute slowly slow very close I
want to point out
that we're like 15 Subs away oh hit that
sub y'all come on 15 of you haven't
subbed to this channel I just want to
point that out let's do the 20K on on
people man remember we have a console to
give away
um if you're part of patreon
that console's up for grabs hit that
subscribe man tell it subscribe there's
833 of you in the chat right now no come
on no y'all subscribers
facts giving y'all good content out here
so
Macho Man 10 super chat oh hell the
MacBook
I hope someone from Sony is listening to
the great Peter because not only is the
PS5 starting fire fires but the building
as well somebody needs to get back to
being great
it's dead they were successful they
didn't learn it blow it up and do what
they were supposed to so now you're
gonna watch them disappear
Ed
11 11 more nice I love a boy let's go
got four y'all now we need another let's
put the crest in the chat
welcome to Lord bronze hindsight with
Hustle No Doubt that's the man slow
thank you tell us to appreciate you
brother that we got Spartan six six one
five dollar Super Chat thank you for the
interviews you guys share with us
everyone here knows all of you are great
at what you do as content creators and
you're and you entertain at IOP thank
you appreciate it thank you much love
much love
we got the homie kiss move two dollar
Super Chat bring back NBA Live Peter
call your buddies yeah yeah okay I shot
the shot for you bro I shot the shot for
you NBA Live I shot the shot for you EA
Sports [__]
let it go you know why Let It Go
you not beating 2K yeah you're so far
behind it's kind of is the basics
the baseball conundrum is like you so
far behind it's crazy like I don't it's
not even so far behind
it don't matter what you do you can have
a superior basketball game to this day
2K dudes a loyal to a point that is
bananas I got dudes that tell me I
already took the week off and I'm going
to spend like a thousand dollars in Vibe
I said oh let's get it let's get it five
minutes okay let's go let's go let's do
it on this show let's do it on this show
man it's the one this is the one
I know some of you PlayStation people I
know you got some uh burner accounts man
then we have mg with the 50 Super Chat
this Peter Moore guy is all right yeah
yes he is it's kind of a big deal he's
so dope that the dude that followed him
almost burnt us to the ground
he's trying to do
the people dominance Maximus really
spent that to step in get this dude off
the chair I can't with you you're messy
super messy right now continue yeah we
got chuckle chuckle with the nine pound
Super Chat just joined and playing catch
up Peter is a proper gent my wife is
from Liverpool and so I have an affinity
for scousers love and well wishes to you
and the Lord sorry more he was talking
that little talk he was talking about
people who gonna be the one though
are you the one to subscribe let's go
and we got zip Davis five dollars
[Laughter]
they want the player to have a
relationship with their car one more
is the last one I want you to I want you
to say who you are yes yes
it might be something special for you
I'm gonna get imma get mine a btpl a
Brazilian tail pipe lift 20
000 Subs oh we did it put it together
we have done it people
rejoice and put your hands put the crust
of the chat put the crash in the chat
y'all 20K put the crush everybody right
now put the questions without you guys
we don't do this don't do this we don't
do this put the crash in the chat right
now that we had to shame y'all to get
there but exactly we had to bully all a
little bit put the Crescent you I want
the chat flooded with the iron Lord
podcast Crest there we go let's see the
Wolves up let's see the shields up let's
go but you wasn't subbed oh my God how
the hell I'm not Subs I'm guarding them
let me let me just give subbing don't
cost you a nickel so exactly don't cost
you a quarter
it don't cost you anything if I'm giving
you this entertainment just give me that
thumbs up and get the next Subs up boys
and ladies thank you so much thank you
so much everybody here we did this
together and we're moving forward yeah
we've been doing this a long time and
like I said you you guys power us and
it's an honor to have some of the best
community ever it's you guys make it fun
and 20K y'all 20 addict okay what we
doing out here 20K 20K seven that's
crazy you showed up let's go appreciate
y'all continue appreciate y'all
appreciate y'all then we got lady saying
50 Super Chat notice that a recruiter is
always coming to Peter this is my story
for those out there that are trying to
uh to up their levels gotta keep your
your LinkedIn profile updated if you
don't have a LinkedIn account or you
don't update it you're doing yourself a
disservice
um
then we got hindsight with hustle member
for 21 months Lord bronze do you
remember a game called wet on the three
things yeah yes is it a Game Pass I
asked because it's made by xenomax yeah
I went to where it wasn't good but you
know wet was wet
actually I like wet yeah it was trying
to do some things
like getting wet but anyway we're gonna
move on
and we got the homie hargit Johnny five
dollar Super Chat would have been
awesome to ask but after ABK is acquired
not sure how long Bobby K will still be
there could Peter be interested in just
saying that'd be crazy if he comes back
into the game before it is sobs I mean
um cogs
um emojis on the side extra large Paws
yeah
that time out is just both yeah that's
that timeout taking up your whole face
punch you in the mouth time
and it's still rolling though let's kill
that time that we got Craig hooligan
gifting and quotations gifting and IOP
membership thank you Craig cool again
you out there in the streets doing the
Lord's work beating people up for
memberships I appreciate it
there we got lady fox fire five dollars
to the chat amazing show as always I've
been a gamer since Sega Genesis days but
hardcore into gaming since the 360
generation thank you for all you guys do
appreciate you thank you so much
appreciate that
then we got hargit chani once again two
dollar Super Chat salute to the Lords
for getting Peter Moore twice yes that
was that was all Peter he was like all
right this is the date can we do it yes
about his business man about business
then we got uh a couple put the crest in
the chat for the next few uh chats that
we have they're all new members we got
Diogo padrao welcome Lord go put the
crest in the chat with Yogo padrao then
we got awful Grim bones welcome to Lord
bronze shout out put the crust in the
chat and we have Captain chats Lord
bronze welcome sir appreciate that with
the crust in the chat and we have Nam
Omar member for 25 months Lord go
congrats on 20K Lords thank you brother
appreciate you
then we got Jay Rembert two dollar Super
Chat congrats on 20K thank you
appreciate that brother
member for 29 months Lord bronze
congratulations Lords I'm so happy for
the Lords thank you appreciate it
then we got uh Mr two opinionated two
dollar Super Chat bring NBA Street back
be different in my opinion that'd be
nice that'd be awesome like Street
um then we got Danny passion official to
a dollar Super Chat congrats great
interview thank you bro appreciate that
then we got Dr Strange Love once again
five dollar Super Chat do you guys think
the industry will be facing a new video
game Crash because all the studio
closure and budgeting can't keep going
at this rate nope
yeah I don't think it's kind of one of
those too big to fail things now like
video games are not where they were back
when E.T sort of slumped the whole
industry so the problem was it was only
uh a couple of major players and yeah
everything was all over the place right
you have clinical Vision you had Amiga
uh the way the PC was set up and you had
Atari Atari was the biggest player out
of all of them but Atari games wasn't
the best out of all of them no right so
you had shovelware being thrown out and
guys turning games around in two weeks
of major uh licenses EA was a I mean um
E.T was a major license that they got
and that game
being shipped out the door in the form
that it was to just meet the movie's
demand
sunk the market so many of those games
was made and the return on those games
the the outcry
people were just fed up we're not at
that point we don't have anything like
that when you got games like Star field
uh you got future game like Spider-Man
coming out you got Forza you you have
all these wonderful games that have
launched Final Fantasy XV
um what is this us uh Stars uh tears of
stars of the Stars uh these games are
taking it to a whole different level now
the sustainability of purchasing all
these quality games in succession that
won't lead to a collapse what that would
do is lead to the rise of the
subscription service that's where we're
going
yeah that's exactly true it's not the
same at all it won't happen again no
then we have Huffy bear CH selfie [__]
five dollar Super Chat shout out to the
Lords for the great content to listen to
while doing my cardio in the gym shut up
you listening to me while you working
out you trying to kill yourself could
you imagine you up under your max press
and I say something stupid you're about
to die well I mean they say cardios
they're probably on a treadmill or
something you know Jefferson oh you
trying to fall you trying to trip
hit your face
I do a lot of cardio every week and I
listen to podcasts while I do cardio you
must be listening to the boring podcasts
there we got wavy kosher remember for
five months Lord bronze shout out to the
Lords for part two with Peter Moore and
hitting 20K also wanted to know when is
fight night coming back finished MK1 and
I'm feeling frisky pause
you saw I shot that shot yeah
pretty much just say look
Fight Night great game just this
extraordinary there's a bunch of
variables one it's just he didn't see a
growing audience is that they're there
they they try to sell to the same people
buying it last last one they try and
sell it to more people and they just
didn't see a growing audience in the
long run I'm gonna tell you what was
more telling in that spot and if you
guys missed it you started off with the
business is kind of grimy
and when you start to deal with the
Slime and the underbelly of the boxing
world you really don't want to deal with
him so he said he sat down with Dana
White and the the Whatchamacallit
Brothers
and those that is a different experience
it is you understand so dealing with all
of that and then licensing each
different character no and you guys are
asking for x amount of dollars where
you're not producing the viewership the
return on investment isn't there we got
to close that part so remember what we
made yeah and that's it that's the thing
like UFC is kind of is a league now
right it's controlled from it's
centralized so the pro the thing with
that is now you have Dana White owns
everything pretty much so it isn't that
nothing but but yeah I mean that the
other part of this bigger thing but the
thing about it is you don't have to
worry about that sort of stuff so you
lose a little bit of something right
because UFC has evolved differently to
what it was but
you don't have those worries with the
sheistiness exactly and having to grease
a lot of pockets so
um
yeah there we got let me see Tony Bryant
member for third no then we have for the
crest in the chat for fan testicles
evolved into
somebody's I was like I'm not reading
these before Peter's still here I can't
do this
now we got Tony Bryant member for 36
months look bronze been here for a while
glad to see 20K live as always a great
time to be a gamer hashtag stop the
leaks I said I'm not leaking anything
else I'm done I'm good
yeah we got C money on point for gamers
ten dollar Super Chat congrats on the
20K lawyers the goats of the podcast
game so well deserved you're an
inspiration to us all glad I could watch
the 20K hit live yes hello salute much
love
then we got Nintendo Taco member for
four months Lord silver salute to the
Lords for 20K the best Xbox podcast
could have been at 50K by now if Cog
would just accept our Lord and savior
Mario
[Laughter]
I do got something
um we originally we were going to talk
this
this week about uh payday three uh but
payday's been having like a lot of
issues like Network wise so I wanted to
make sure that like we got a good
experience when they get their whole
networking issue stuff so we'll talk
about that next week yeah we maybe could
get some things guys uh Lords check to
chat when you guys get a chance it's
kind of important
remaining ones
we're caught up so let me check that
chat room yeah check the uh ILP chat so
um I know we want to do the uh things we
want to talk about or you know if we're
going we're going to talk about what we
powered by what we're gonna do all right
let's let's pick let's pay the bills
okay and then get and then we'll power
up all right cool cool let's pay the
bills so so I have give you a moment
don't worry while you do that some I
think two came in and um I'll take care
of that for you JD gamer five dollar
Super Chat uh congratulations on 20K not
at the ABK Gail's done who's next call
the next acquisition's out
and then angry hippie follow Troopers
had did anyone else hear Howard could
costell's voice doing Peter at least or
yes yes sir
that was oh that was the only thing I
heard when he said that down goes
Frasier yeah that's right all right
we're caught up there okay so Gentlemen
let's uh let's pay these bills let's pay
these bills everybody mute uh again
apologies for The Voice
but
support for the iron Lords podcast is
brought to you by manscaped who is the
best in men's below the waist grooming
their products are Precision engineered
uh for your family jewels badscape
performance package the ultimate men's
uh hygiene bundle join over 8 million
men worldwide who trust manscape with
this exclusive offer for you 20 off and
free worldwide shipping with the code
iron Lords at manscape.com if my math is
correct that's about 16 million balls so
as summer comes to an end and fall is
upon us the change in the weather means
we'll be putting away our shorts our
sandals and t-shirts and pulling out our
jackets sweaters and heavy pants and
before Long Winter will be knocking at
our door forcing us to wrap ourselves in
heavy coats scarves and snow boots now
this nippy weather may have you thinking
hey baby it's cold outside and my
Nethers can use all the warmth they can
get
maybe I can go without shaving down
below for a while maybe the entire
winter season it'll be fine no one will
notice the smell the wife will still be
able to find the Glizzy and tater tots
well I'm here to emphatically say no no
no no no no
at no point in time is it okay to go
unquath down below no matter what 1970s
erotica may have to say about it
self-grooming and thank goodness that
manscaped is here to save you from
yourself because the performance package
4.0 has arrived and oh man it is it is a
game changer inside this package you'll
find that lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed
whacker era nose nose hair trimmer crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold your goodies first
off the lawnmower 4.0 this trimmer is
the future of grooming and dare I say
the greatest ball trimmer ever I can
concur their fourth generation trimmer
features a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to the
Advanced Skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 is waterproof and also has
4 000 LED spotlights so you can get a
more precise shave because this trimmer
is waterproof you can say goodbye to the
mess on the bathroom floor you thought
that was good but you want to take your
grooming game even further to the next
level the performance package 4.0 also
includes the weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer the weed whacker is also
waterproof and provides proprietary skin
safe technology which helps reduce Nicks
snags and tugs in those delicate nose
holes their crop preserver ball
deodorant and crop reviver ball toner
will change the way you approach your
hygiene routine trust me when I say this
fellas your balls will thank you
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
their performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxers and the Shad travel bag
bring your comfort and boxers to another
level it's time to take care of yourself
so go to manscape.com and get 20 off and
free shipping with code iron Lords get
20 off and free shipping with the code
iron Lords at manscape.com that's 20 off
with Street free shipping at
manscape.com and use code iron Lords
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscaped
no doubt no doubt thank you sir
addressing the nether regions that is
correct that's not that's not assume
that the winter time is okay don't do
this no no no no wear some wear some
long johns you know try to tell me what
to do no don't do that no that's not
that's not nice you know what I mean
there's other ways to get warm so let's
let's follow those rules sir no doubt no
doubt so look I mean Cog you still got
the sponsor thing up oh thank you thank
you I'm off I'm a little off my game
some stuff going on in the background I
apologize oh my god that hurt yeah yeah
yeah
you all right you're right yeah I'm good
all right cool no doubt no doubt so um
look uh as you could see in the overlay
Lord's uh seemed a bit powered up
surging with that enzyme
you know we want to talk about briefly
this amazing partnership as you see that
purple Power surging all that PC power
in the banner feeding the crest of the
Lords the wolf everything with the glow
up so again put the crest in the chat
again you know if you're looking for a
new PC build or check out the uh we
pinned it at the top you know in the
live chat you can check out you can use
that link when you order and we got more
cool things in the round planned with
NZXT and this partnership so you want to
salute and again thanks to you guys all
this stuff will be possible but uh real
briefly Lloyds you know anyone want to
comment on that there's a partnership in
here these new uh things going on oh I
got my PC
I got the giant box and I was like whoa
dude
then I opened it up and I was like man
purple lights and I ain't gonna lie man
I'm not gonna lie at all I felt I felt
real cool at that point I mean I had a
PC before and I had a gaming PC
but this thing took it to the next level
so when we were
um getting in and we were going through
the choosing you know I chose the the
AMD Edition
and I thought that it was just you know
the coolest looking one the spec wise it
was fantastic you know player three AMD
Edition
top of the food chain I was worried
about Starfield people I'm not gonna sit
here I'm not gonna lie to you
sovereign's background says it all uh
NZXT proved me right
um my choice was right
Starfield y'all guys talking about 60
frames per second
you people don't know what speed is
this game looks
in credible
4K above 60 frames per second
this machine is a monster
um yeah I'm tweaking and twerking with
you dudes
it's Sovereign loves the fact that uh
that now I gotta get steamed you know
what soft did I gotta really break it
down
you know no because I gotta I gotta out
you in front of everybody
um I was worrying about playing a
particular game
and you know we hit up the iron bank
like yo we want to do this but but
addict didn't even worry about hitting
up the iron bank he said yo when
Whatchamacallit this game is on sale I
don't want to say which game it is but
you know this game is on sale uh let's
get it and he's just regularly talking
so Along Comes The Devil he pops up hey
man
I can get that to you right now man and
I'm like yeah but we want to play it on
this no
you got these powerful Rigs and you're
going to play it here yeah he did that
with a couple of games
um you know being that you know he's
he's uh in in that world you know to
keep the tweaking in the twerking world
so I'm not gonna lie you know solve is
right all the time when it comes to this
tweaking and twerking stuff uh him and I
used to do it back in the days but um
NZXT
has allowed us to do it on a greater
scale and I gotta been in need of my man
he's definitely right
I'm not gonna lie bro yeah you're right
I was doing some stuff on that uh on the
rig and it's ridiculous but no doubt
Lloyd's um unfortunately I have an
emergency so I have to cut but I want to
keep uh attic if you can take control I
apologize bro something real serious
says it's going on and I have to leave
but the show will continue adding you
you got everything on the control side I
hope yeah I can I can just cut the
podcast to the YouTube Studio let me
know again apologies a little emergency
going on that's why things were beeping
earlier and I'm being instructed I gotta
get out so I'll be back and again Rome
thank you so much 20K the whole bit and
if we do have to make it up to you we
make it up to you but Lord you guys hold
it down for me
I have to be safe thank you yep
absolutely bro